two hello everybody it's Monday it is
September
11th didn't want to be the one to say it
but that hey that's not a punch line
dude this is serious day Zach take that
back take it back bro I take it back
thank you now you're why' you play a rim
shock cuz there was two drum bees just
like two towers fell that day oh jeez
it's just not cool that you would make
fun of
that not today
bro welcome
everybody Welcome uh thanks for being
here hope you all had a good
weekend youall had a good weekend yeah
yeah yeah poor Ela man she um was meant
to go to Fashion Week her first time she
was so
excited she got these really great
invites and stuff and
then I drove her to the airport
on uh Saturday
evening and I dropped her off and I'm
halfway home and then she called me and
she's like the flight is cancelled
o I was like what and I
guess there was like a massive
thunderstorm and they were canceling all
the flights we we were trying to
scramble to get her anything
you know but uh in the end there was
just she she had no way to get
there so I turned around I sat in the uh
LAX you know the the round circle yeah
yeah I sat in that for like 3
hours if she tried to figure out oh yeah
it wasn't the traffic I was just
waiting and um well she didn't get to go
so that sucks I didn't realize that
happened you might say it's her own
yep not the rim
shot
Zach no it wasn't that bad but it was
sad it was sad so my heart goes out to
her for that
certainly
um wait it's a fashion week though right
well so she was going later she was
going after it already started
oh her mom was here and she wanted to
spend a few days with her gotcha um you
guys have any plans for 911 what are you
guys doing
I am uh pledging my allegiance to the
flag saying how much I love America
that's always a good idea yeah do you
know the Pledge of Allegiance thank you
Lina do you know the pledges of
Allegiance can you stand up right hand
over your
heart loyalty test I pledge allegiance
to the flag of the United States of
America to the Republic for which it
stands one nation God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all the creepiest thing they make kids
do since Hitler
Youth that shit's so crazy man it's my
first um 911 as an America very cool
very cool
congratulations um 91 how you going to
make a 5-year-old pledge allegiance to a
flag
I can't even get him to pledge
allegiance to his favorite uh
Paw Patrol dinosaur yeah exactly I
promise to die for the flag for the
freedoms and ideals under
God you're
five well you don't want to hear about
911 that's what the teacher
like uh actually shout out to Wally P
shout out the originator of all 911
jokes he invented the genre of
Comedy here he is Jo B wake up Joe Biden
wake up
911 to same day what happened
2011 this is w
p Texas USA 24/7 every day I'm wake up
in USA Joe Biden 2001 was
Jo
W he did
w how Pentagon hit by rocket Pentagon
hit by
rocketed Pentagon was hit by rocket hit
by a rocket well that was the conspiracy
right that it was hit by a missile or
something yeah yeah W bush sent it yeah
cross Red Cross Christian Red Cross in
the in the rocket H Christian Red Cross
in the rocket the red the Red Cross was
involved first to I see the right copy
this way the it a we got silenced damn
damn uh but yeah what what year what
year was that 2020 I think yeah
2020 no no no 911
2011 2001 so was that 911 22 years ago
yes sir
not that long ago actually I mean my ass
is 38 minus 22 let's do some arithmetic
here 16 I
was when I watched those Towers go down
man
wow you guys remember where you were on
911 I think we did this last year the
same exact conversation yeah where were
you on 911 you weren't even born huh I
was born you're like one but just for a
little bit I was like a year year old
barely born so you're saying so what
you're telling me is you don't remember
I don't and that's disgraceful
bro but the idea is to never forget but
if he didn't know in the first place
then there's he was there man don't make
excuses okay I was there I was there
true I support genocide that's it's not
true not excuse me not cool for today
have some respect yeah it's not true it
was a horrible thing though that
happened and uh
you know everyone who was affected on
that day is uh is a tragedy
so cheers my dudes cheers my dude cheers
my dude love
you that was a scary time um we got a
good show here today despite the uh
solemnness in the air and the Asbestos
and the uh dust what i is this is my in
poor taste yet or or no no okay I think
so far so good so far so
good you would say that I
would just kidding all right I got to
get
together
uh we got a good show here
today we've got a uh 23 and me results
this is exciting we sent away for these
a few weeks ago AB Lena and Zach are new
entries wait Sam did you do one I did it
a while back oh okay so she had results
and then I have my dad's results cuz you
won't do it cuz I won't do it but my dad
is a fool and gave his DNA over to
Amazon
Incorporated um so I have his results so
I have half of so if your mom does it
then we got the whole thing exactly but
um she's smart she's tooart will your
mom do it can it I pay for it she's too
smart for
that our DNA history what is that term
she knows her worth our DNA history
uh so we've got mine and elas from a
while back but we have three new ones
and the question we were looking to
answer was essentially because you guys
were saying you were like 100% Lebanese
right no not me Lena Lena thought yeah
most so we wanted to analy we wanted to
test that theory and ab what were you
guessing your heritage was just 5050
5050 mine me up a little bit but
wait you guys looked at it already mhm
we looked at our own but I don't we
haven't cross
[Music]
examined this is like love eating the
french fries before the taste test I
never did that was that you I remember
did that I would never that was me oh
that was cam
right doing a taste test and cam starts
eating the damn food before the segment
and the Mr Beast Burger too no no that's
why we don't give you food around here
yeah or maybe that's why he did it cuz
he doesn't get food he was starving
all right so that's coming up we have
some insane eight passenger updates I
mean this lady is just
nuts I'm so glad she's arrested and
she's in a jumpsuit because she is
a she's a real baset
case
damn okay can I say
this always a good
start here we go can I say this can I
say this um
no God what is wrong with
you love SS it might be okay no don't
listen to
love I mean it's on theme oh is it it's
on theme I wasn't it was a I was I was
planning
a combo uh 8 passenger 911 joke it was
funny I'll say that it you shouldn't say
it who's going to get mad and it's not
funny F YouTube her she going to get she
going to complain from prison probably
YouTube is probably the biggest concern
here not funny mhm okay I won't say
it shame so we got that we've got the
the Jimmy Fallon Fallout is pretty
interesting we've got Danny Masterson
the it's not it's not interesting that
he was um sentenced for 30 years for
being an rorist the interesting part was
how Ashton K ker and mil Mila Kunis
straight up hijacked a plane and flew it
into the towers of their career to
defend a freaking
awardist like
why you know what I mean it's so
senseless tragedy it's I mean what the
hell it's crazy met today are beautiful
so that's going to be interesting to
talk about then they got the apology
tour no cam what are you doing
made his wish can I open this no I don't
even know what it means I think I
understand I don't even know what it
means I'll open it I think it's fine
right well maybe not I don't know I
don't think so all right it I won't
open
it we'll never
forget should I post it on
Twitter yeah put it on Twitter I mean
it's not that oh put it on Twitter and
then the joke I was going to say can we
do that nah oh maybe I shouldn't
have
why Twitter is let's just forget about
it so moving quickly up on um so this is
a this is a song that dropped and
everybody's been really enjoying it the
guys backstage have been really uh
enjoying it the crew now I don't know
anything about enjoying well I don't
want to make I don't necessarily want to
make fun of him because he I mean listen
he traveled A Thousand Miles uh
kilometers he's so less but he's putting
in the work yes is is this his account
Fus has fat
nuts I don't think
so I don't believe so oh here it is it's
Shan Sean uh Sean Stevens Sean Stevens
music send me his uh I want to check out
his I don't know you got y all sent me
the original version of Pingus has fat
nuts
account well done oh my God I win
thank you
guys that was my bad dud
it yeah I want cuz I mean at least I
want to look I want to get a picture of
who he is AB linked his uh the actual I
like he's giving like um I he's G giving
like a middle management Joker yeah uh
he's actually a CEO he's very and which
is a fact he's very proud of is he
really yeah that's his whole gimmick is
he a CE he's a CEO by day and a whatever
this is by night he's a rockar By Night
guess
fat nuts I had this link so fast cuz I
had it ready I was about to put in the
doc and Z like no no I got it and then
he put the fat nuts together this is the
version I I pulled from is that your
account
Zach bingus has fat nuts I just love how
it made love
laugh it's good what's he a CEO
of uh he owns some uh marketing company
or something okay so is he so if he's
wealthy then and like he's doing well in
life then I that seems to be what's
going on is he's got like some tech uh
company well then that's fine it's not
like a dude who has nothing and we're
like grounding him into dust for you
know what I mean but here he is Shan
Stevens music and he he sort of embraced
the he he knows that he's the subject of
some mockery on the internet okay and
he's he's embraced the meme well we love
you in fact the one that you're hovering
over right now we can we let's come back
to rectangle yeah but this that's the
one where I was saying he's leaning into
the meme a little bit so add that to the
dock I can open it up right after but so
I see he's posted this quite a few times
yes a lot and they're versions they're
all in Time Square he he keeps traveling
a thousand kilometers and then uh no
some of them one takes place in the in
at the Canadian Parliament and yeah he's
uh in DC for some of them he's taking
all around the world he's on a world
tour so where is the original one cuz I
want to see the cuzz the one you link
doesn't have a lot of views is this it
performing my new I TR okay for my new
song of Time Square rectangulars is out
today so I'd love to hear what you think
first of all shout out to Shawn Stevens
for not claiming the song yeah no well
he like I said CEO of a marketing
company he knows the biz we love that he
knows the biz uh the comments this is
one of the songs of all time Chad is
this real people think it's AI is this
real or AI lyrical
genius so I don't know I mean it's kind
of a it's kind of all right let's just
listen let's drop the track yeah km to
New York City to do
this I am he could have done that at
home though well he did as well okay
just saying could have done it at home
twice yeah but it didn't get almost I
traveled 1 th000 km to New York City to
do
this I am
reang sorry the way he hits that first
word he just misses you gotta just play
this song I'm sorry you can tell he
wants to hit it so hard but he still
came in late it's like delayed it's a
little bit of a swing it's a swing feel
he he opens his mouth like this you
wouldn't
understand I see why people think they
are
rectangular I Feel It In My Bones I am
rectangular feel no hole I
am so he says I'm rectangular I don't
feel a hole implying that he's not a
circle but circles don't have holes
there is a lot of anti- circle
discrimination in the song I Would
Trier Trier dude circles are like
perfect geometric shapes you at the
sphere you look at the Circle I mean an
egg an egg well that's an if it's a
perfect shape why do you need an
irrational number to express its radius
it's the one that's because it's divine
bro I don't know about a circle it's
divine Pi can never Pi never finishes
it's infinite like God
rectangles could have circles in them
you know the outer shape doesn't
preclude there being some sort of hole
what does that have to do with a
rectangular you can you can fit you can
also fit a giant turd in a rectangular I
what's your point you can fit a lot of
things in there well he's saying I'm
rectangular I got no holes but I'm
saying those aren't mutually exclusive
you know what Dan you're sound like a
square well he said well he right true
true let's let that ring out for a
minute okay let's I'm just going to let
it play you guys I'm
sorry in myones
amang feel no I am
rectangular and you are a circle so is
that a disc yeah you're a circle that's
what I'm saying what the which is
weird cuz like AB noted rectangular or
you're square is an insult square is a
type of rectangle MH but he's flipping
that he's saying no you're a circle
I'm a rectangle
I am
rectangular you no I am
rectangular and you are a cirle I
am he forgot his own lyrics I mean look
at this he lost his
[Music]
place cuz he put his arms up to be a
rectangle there there oh yeah he he
right here he loses his spot right yeah
it's right here well this is like very
uh circular
Behavior what was that
line that's true well it's a sphere but
it is I guess circular yeah also side
note I I came a th000 kilm to New York
to do this also the famous last words of
the terrorists
911 that's true how far how far is
Boston to New York well I have seen he
goes to like the all the main he all his
videos had big government buildings he
very sus oh no interesting he does go to
DC he everything that's what I'm I'm
going to oh I'm going to compliment
him I think he has a nice voice got like
a really nice po voice we've been
singing it for the last week we made our
own version he sounds like one of these
pop radio
voices uh but it seems to be missing
like a qu is there more is this the
whole song uh no there's more there's
more I want the full version just heads
up that this is only what I've checked
um I haven't checked a full me song
doesn't get claimed yeah so does he have
other songs or is this it um you know I
he has at least one other song he's got
a good voice man yeah you fan I do I do
think so and I I like the I like the
idea of the you're I'm a rectangle
you're a circle like as a concept it's
like hey we're just different but I
don't see I don't like how he goes like
I don't have holes he tries to make it
personal here's what I don't get is he
says I'm a rectangle I'm a lost soul he
did say that yeah so is he possibly
saying a circle is a found Soul it's a
whole it's a hole I think he's just
trying to say that the world there's a
lot of circles in the world and he feels
like an outsider as a rectangle he
doesn't fit in that's beautiful yeah so
he's like a rectangle going through a
circular hole well let me hear the whole
song so we can analyze this further I
don't I don't hate it you know like as a
concept it's working for me okay we uh
we also you know what else was uh
rectangular oh God uh the Twin Towers
yeah yeah I thought the Pentagon
bringing it back home that that would be
incred the Pentagon is not re that's
literally a shape in
to his credit uh I love this guy I think
he sounds like Peter Gabriel yeah yeah
yeah we've been talking a lot about the
Peter Gabriel listen to like red rain
yeah Peter Gabriel D I agree I
think he Dave Matthews someone said I
see that oh yeah I see that for sure I
see the Dave ma Dave Boston to New York
is 2 okay what is this this isn't funny
guys this is not funny dude stop posting
this
it's not
funny no dude actually you know what's
crazy I forgot how rectangular the Trade
Towers were very like they are so
angular very angular very
rectangular
amang wait so Boston and New York's only
uh 346 km but they flew further than
that I thought no they took off from
Logan
Airport did they fly straight surely not
maybe they took some detour well I know
I remember they did some up
where it was like meant for La so it had
more fuel right right right
demons really were demons those it's a
rainy day out here in Los
Angeles all right let's get the full
version it is it's actually a beautiful
day out here in Los Angeles gorgeous
gorgeous it's been nice hot oh
yeah I feel it in my hole Yeah it's a
lat we made our we made our own version
oh okay did y'all send the full one I'm
looking for I know I don't know if I've
ever seen the full thing no I saw it on
only ever seen Clips I am rect you
should watch the one with his employes
yeah okay I'll pull that up but try to
find the whole one first hey guys I'm oh
where'd it go here here's the uh
employee there's a clip go look for the
clip seems like a nice guy I wonder cuz
like here he is in his office hey guys
I'm here at does he have a billion
dollar smile all
right that's all right
oh my God
maybe that looks like a billion dollar
smile guys I'm here at tree frog and
there's a whole bunch of people here and
they were really excited to sing my new
song rectangle every ready I'm just
going to flip the camera around
here
God this is a joke right this I did
think they okay good good but it's
probably a little hint of Truth in
here this pretty good it's a funny joke
I am
rectangular that's
good I am rectangular I like it
that's a good bet yeah I agree what do
you guys think about the tables and
everything matching his hair color let
me see let's take a real critical look
at the office people here and they were
really excited to sing my new song
rectangle they ready just going to flip
the camera he loves green huh like the
money of color or the color of money eh
I mean yeah it's like AstroTurf green
too oh and he does have AstroTurf on the
floor yeah and the walls are paint and
on the wall why does he have little
dollops of grass AstroTurf the glasses
like the customers are drinking I mean
the employees are drinking out of I am
inside your walls it's very green man
likes green what's the problem you I
want to know do you like why do you like
Green cuz if he says money then he's
just a player he's a hustler well and
you got to respect the hustle his
company was called like tree something
so you know what I just noticed probably
look at this Frame there are a lot of
circles here yeah Circle tables circles
on the wall wait money's rectangular you
know what I can't even spot of like
self-contained rectangle in the whole
goddamn room yeah oh maybe the uh the
lights the lights of on feeling
rectangular
right I like
him I like it I'm I'm a fan of
his did we get a longer version yeah oh
wonderful wonderful music video oh good
is it here is the uh oh no it's not a
music video is it well we have art and
maybe this oh look see I was right I was
right he's a he's a square peg going
through a round hole this guy this is
what I was saying this this art is going
to help us figure this out mhm but what
happened there's no rectangular shape I
mean it's a square it's a shape box
rectangular yeah that's a cube that's a
cube the green right is a cube not a
rectangle the a rectangle is
specifically a type it's where two sides
are longer than the other two sides
correct yeah in parallel wait yeah so
that's a cube that's up he
up bro you chose this image after all
this analysis and careful word play the
cube that's disappointing that's IUD bro
that's really disappointing all right
let's listen
up no close captions
to comment's off come on wait it says
it's on this Str kid
uhoh yeah but remember we learned from
that it's a it's a conscious decision if
you want a claim or not I think do we
check it first I mean we already
listened to like a whole last minute of
it yeah if it was going to get claimed
it would have got claimed from that Tik
Tok it was a minute all right let's
let's well let's do this not then we go
to war with the Sean I'll show you what
a rectangle looks like
rectangular it's the it's the shape of a
paper served to your ass in a
lawsuit that's
right I feel it in myones I am
rectangular feel no hole I am
rectangular and you are a circle I am
[Music]
rectang can you get Michael Jackson ah
ah
I like the music too it's kind of
fire
reang he loves the
chorus really
[Music]
just oh wao there another part oh
this part is good and he also says my
whole life which is kind of of circular
wait okay that was a sick breakdown hold
on let me back it
[Music]
up what the are you loving this I'm
loving this dude what a curveball holy
all right hold on let's listen it
now this is good
[Music]
it is very Dave Matthew
SE for the one who
is I
am is right back on it here let me read
you the words he
says my whole life lonely trying to find
the promise to me I'll hit the bottom
touch the sky giving Shrek
Rock rip searching for the one who is
mine I am rectangular I feel it in my
bones I am rectangular I feel no whole
he doesn't say feel he says I feel no
feel no hole well there could be a
rectangular hole exists yeah for sure
it's just a square hole they're not
exclusively circles right yeah but maybe
but okay I see where I see where he's
going with that oh also I I just got an
interesting note that uh every square is
a rectangle yeah a square is a type of
rectangle right but we were saying so
theoretically wouldn't all that Cube
would we were criticizing him for the
choice of using a cube or because it's
Square on each side but if all squares
are rectangles then technically we still
looking at a rectangle of sorts well no
well all squares are re or no all
rectangles are squares but all
rectangles not all
rectangles but wait I thought a
rectangle okay hold on let me Define
where are all equal sides rectang this
throws everything into because then but
I okay hold on there's there's something
we're missing here in the
definition because I think maybe maybe
the rectangle as we know it is a
specific type of rectangle you know what
I mean I think a rectangle just has to
have uh you know a plain figure with
four straight sides and four right
angles especially one with unequal
adjacent sides in contrast to a square
so that's what we popularly know it as
that but a rectangle I guess technically
just needs four sides and four right
angles right which a square would
fulfill the requirements of okay so Sean
I apologize we gave but he's not a cube
a cube is still well a cube is just a
three-dimensional version of a square a
sphere is not a
circle right but I mean okay yeah you
know I I was giving a little bit of
leeway for the extra Dimension well if
we're going to I mean if we're going to
nitpick be consistent right right right
right right right right right
right um let me continue the
lyrics he says he goes on he
continues I'm a lost soul I'm Holding On
by a
thread holding down life before dead I'm
waking up pushing through don't know how
I find you how I find you how I find you
I am a rectangular I Feel It In My Bones
I am rectangular I'm a lost soul I'm
rectangular the world is a circle I am a
rectangle a
rectangular I am rectangular I'm a lost
soul the puffer fish right the one that
turns into a
circle right so
isang feel in
[Music]
myang just go crazy with the MJ stuff
for a second
[Music]
sure I'm Holding
On by a friend
hold
down okay wait hold on let me open the
whale
sounds the whale sounds yeah cuz oh
interesting I I have them saved actually
we're talking about two-dimensional
shapes here so does he is he 2D I'm
trying to add another dimension right
with the whales okay and maybe a brown
sound turn up the whale
[Music]
sound okay let me turn this down
there you go and
then maybe some sounds of the
city because he's a city slicker I mean
he went to New
York
okay here we go open window New York
City perfect oh my
God why
the the whale I can't look at oh is it
really scare you oh my goodness it's so
[Music]
big and then um can you turn up the city
sound uh
it's can we get us a lightning is
evening thunderstorm sound of
thunderstorm sure sure
[Music]
yeah here let me start it over what what
love I said there's some McDonald's ASMR
by E the
Klein
all right I'm starting it
over
good what do you so this is kind of an
interesting version
remix okay now can you add Subway Subway
Ambient
sound thank
you I'm myestro of
this Orchestra
um should I I can open the
subway get
Subway sounds for
sleeping like Subway restaurant or like
oh no no no I meant like here oh I got
it I got it I got it like the sounds of
the city you know what I mean and then
can we get people going like hey I'm
walking here
just like people chatting in the
[Music]
background the scams in New York
City then can you turn off his music a
little bit I I can't hear it I don't
want to I don't want to forget the soul
of this good
good thank
you it's playing already
maybe okay
now there's something else we're
missing we
miss oh we didn't get lightning sounds
thunder sounds thunder sounds for
sleeping oh that's
go we need thunder cuz it's Stormy in
New York as we learn my wife my El you
know got
cancelled we have maybe some Flappy Bird
Flappy Bird gam play some flppy
bird all right all right we got to stop
hold on hold on no we got to stop now we
need the brown
sound hold on this is the last one that
will perfect it brown sound
uh 10
hours okay go
ahead help me Obie danobi you're my only
hope okay I'm walking
[Applause]
here now we're talking now this is a
song
baby cut it off cut we can kill it we
can kill it all right thank you God I
don't know what's the problem I mean I
was working on the song man trying to
give him some tips how to make it more
dimensional cheers my
dude oh come on tomatoes in chat you
guys that's not cool don't throw
tomatoes at Sean he's trying his best
tomatoes you're killing
me all
right it's good not bad eh shout out to
to
um I feel it in my hole shout out shout
out uh to Sean I want to give you a full
shout out here to Pingus has fat nuts on
YouTube shout out Pingus it's a Sean
stefin music there it
is wait Stevens Stevens sorry Sean
Stevens I am re I guarantee everybody
listening is going to be listening to
stuck in your head I am
rectangular should I link it in the bio
sure it check out our boy Sean
Stevens on Tik Tok vas has fat nuts he
should make a song about being green h
that could be an interesting that seems
more personal to him perhaps I would
listen to that we have a great new
animation coming from uh a Street
podcast animated this person story
before dedicated as it comes they make
one of
these pretty regular
eh yeah they've been pumping them out
yeah this one actually was nice to to
see this visualize told a story before
but people were they were yo-yoing
everywhere kids were yo-yoing in the
street it's true this is how I remember
it and so I was in the grocery store and
I was yo-yoing down the produce
aisle and there's this trick you might
know it's called around the world
classic classic was prac my around the
world until I noticed there was a bit of
an impact on the behind me when I
was it was an old lady I hit her right
in the face and the glasses no I
knocked her glasses off her
face wow I'm falling and I can't she she
she's confused she doesn't understand
what's happen she man got twirling a
yo-yo in the grocery store my word I've
never she was just stunned and confused
and I think I ran off cuz I was so
embarrassed yeah she was fine I think
she was
fine honestly uh nice it did really
bring me back to that moment Sig little
me in the grocery store that's H3
podcast animated if y'all want to check
out what's the most popular one he he
makes so many short King let me see this
here's another short King he went from
wow really bro you going to put me with
big ass titties like that
come on now I guess it is from a year
ago titch here's another short
King he went from 53 to 58 so this guy
got dude that's crazy he got five Ines
that's pretty
significant this story was so up
he was a tiny little D he hated himself
and I spit on him when he came in the
office he says there's nothing worse
than being short I literally kicked him
in the balls and called him a tiny
yeah enan stands at 59 he's still a
short piece of but he's not as bad
as he used to be that's so weird the
demean is yeah why does he talk that way
what the dude I I don't know if we
talked about this there's this other guy
who was
like he was like 5'7 or something and
now he's like six feet
yeah he loves it though he he doesn't
regret it at all man right yeah he's
super
happy I can't get over the thought that
I could be like
65 that' be so crazyd be tall than Hanan
one day one day for no reason these are
pretty funny here's one about Ryan
kavana I can't resist look at this I
just typed Ryan Kavanaugh wife and then
this one came up oh that's the one I'm
looking at yeah God he is such a
honk though he's so hot how dude that
guy's in the gym like all day sure and
that's natural too no roids you think so
oh yeah boy look at those
veins holy man thanks for taking
care of her bro how old do you think he
is God look at that at that age lot
younger than Ryan Kavanagh that's for
sure at that age with those abs
brother God you must be a Dynamo
in the sack dude probably got endurance
so much endurance probably go for 8
hours straight
man golly
dude good looking dude on the right
that's Brad oh that's Brad yeah what do
you say about this one
Ela it's just so silly dude this photo
makes
[Music]
noet yeah good call thank you for saying
that cuz I was like oh boy I forgot I
had it we had the button out of that
there was a gra really got a little too
graphic for it was funny I didn't want
to risk it you know can go watch it
yourself you know when you do a podcast
you don't want to getour you to go watch
your entire day demonetized because of
one half second of dumb yeah it's not
worth it oh you know how we we were
thirst trapping for um Thor the wood
cutter mhm so ladies what yeah I don't
remember what he's the he was the um the
uh Lumberjack the super hot Lumberjack
oh okay I kind of remember that
mhm I
remember oh yeah and so actually ladies
and well anyone out there who wants a
piece of the action get ready because I
didn't know this man could get any
hotter but here he is speaking to my
soul it's preach it brother he actually
is speaking to my soul in a serious way
people will take him seriously cuz he's
hot and buff but I've said the same
thing now while I wanted to make you
guys a wood splitting video today I'm
going to do things a little bit
differently post today you can do the
things however you could do things any
way you want on me baby go right ahead
split my wood wide open Bradly Thor is
that really his name no shot come on
thank you uh uh Devin thank you guys for
always being a lot of fun and great
distraction husband is going in for bone
marrow transplant oh
no that's it's a tough one I wish him
luck wish you both
luck um Britney been watching for years
I look forward to every episode such a
fan of Ethan and Ne the crew work at an
anbal Hospital currently paying myself
through vet school sorry for your lost
of Shredder well that's awesome I love
vets I mean good vets really are a great
source of comfort people so good for you
Saints All right so anyway back to dude
Thor could literally split me from dick
to head bro in one swing
and I wouldn't even
complain that made me a little bit angry
and I want to talk about it there is a
very
well-known a few but one specifically
very well-known Fitness company that
made a post or a video likening the gym
to therapy um it isn't therapy
now just pause it here and make his
poignant Point here it's not just this
company this is like every I hear this
now all the time this is like the gym
Bros they go I don't they literally say
I don't need therapy I just go to the
gym like that's something they tell each
other um and this is part of what I'm
not against Fitness I just think this
whole idea that the gym is going to
solve all the problems in your life has
just gotten a little bit silly so preach
it Thor talk to me
Daddy I'm psyched that so many new
people are enthralled about fitness and
health health and wellness uh the space
is growing and that's a good thing but
trading drinks for dumbbells trading
bars for barbells do this whole concept
of people making themselves a martyr to
this hustle porn really is what it is is
not healthy um one addiction for another
is still an addiction even if it's a
healthy thing to be completely honest
with you compulsive behavior is
compulsive by any measure and just
because it happens to be
uh culturally viewed as a healthy
activity this is another good point that
I've tried to make if you go to the gym
seven days a week and eat only red meat
and like that's not good for you bro
your heart is your heart is going to be
up y'all just saying man like
obviously it's unhealthy but if you're
munching
on a straight if you're just putting
straight up eggs in your mouth and
chewing them uncooked I've seen that
with the shell yep like it's a Milk
Dud and because you don't have time to
leave the gym because you need to keep
lifting it's not good for you I mean you
look cool but let's be
real doesn't mean that your behaviors
are
healthy I cannot tell you how many times
I've heard people say the phrase the gym
is cheaper than therapy yes because I
can assure you passing on your traumas
your issues use your setbacks onto the
next person onto the Next Generation
onto your loved ones will not be cheaper
right well said please be
careful not turning yourself into a
martyr please be careful to not spray
paint your demons gold oh because they
will come back
beautiful exercise is
healthy but it's not everything yo I get
the feeling he knows we should get we
should get him to call in I want to talk
to this man that's so now he's
deep now can we reach out to Thor for
sure I need to talk to this
man I'm deep and Thor can you when you
call in can you have a bicep Cam that we
can cut
to can we set that up yeah I think so
stop painting your Demon's gold is very
beautiful interesting um but actually
I'm listen hopefully if a big buff dude
can say it then maybe they'll listen to
him but he made a really good point here
demons gold because they will come back
exercise is
healthy but it's not everything thank
you brother thank you careful well said
not turning yourself into a martyr
please be care I I don't even know if
it's the Martyr thing I feel like
they're they're you get so ingrained in
this culture you don't want to
like you feel embarrassed if you're
going to therapy it's like bro why are
you doing that just hit the
gym you
know uh you're afraid of being
judged
uh but there it is Thor we love him for
that this is interesting comment he's so
right the gim and healthy eating can
help with mental health but if you're
using it to avoid processing emotions
trying to manage those mental health
issues they can manifest in unhealthy
obsessions with the body very well said
and then of course the second one being
uh even more insightful just when I
thought my busy couldn't get any
wetter
exactly we love
thorm don't we
folks do we love Thor
folks yes we do what he's saying is I'm
against glaze glazing he believes in
raw beautiful he's 5'6 no he's not
somebody said that in chat find the he's
at least 6'3 I can
tell no shot and just just a a thigh
slapper dude wait there's a lot of
people saying that that's weird there's
no way dude there's no way uh this
random articles is roughly
5'9 yo he hits that like low angle yeah
yeah
know we got to get him leg St uh leg
lengthening does this change your
perspective we'll make you we're going
to make you six7 bro does this change
your your feelings towards him like a
Gary ve yeah different perspectives no
cuz he he's not as tall as you think it
does I I I all of a sudden don't really
want him on the show
anymore short you know I mean these are
all over the place I'm seen some say 6
foot some say
5'7 well let's talk to him wow that'll
be my first
question he's 5'6 then just hang up on
him oh here here or lower and can you
attach this in our email to him um thank
you Daddy him cutting me in two and one
Fell
Swoop powerful
mhm H here's a post from the sub this
was like unreasonably good not something
I'd usually pull up but when I look
through this I was like
what why is this so accurate they did
everyone in the H2 universe as a Disney
villain as
bus okay I don't know who this guy is
frankly that I
got this made me realize I'm out of
touch with a lot of the Disney stuff cuz
I don't recognize quite a few of these
that's the dude from Treasure Planet
Pinocchio Treasure Planet
yeah as Disney's Pinocchio all right
maybe just go look at it maybe this just
one like trying to explain a dream maybe
it's just not going to be that good to
talk about but go check it out dreamed I
saw
my but they're all really good and I'm
glad that J shedy got like the ultimate
demon he's just what is this from that's
from Fantasia oh oh yes he is like that
isn't he that's my favorite Satan
basically he just is Satan he pretty
much is
um new crazy okay Jesus Christ we keep
going down these weird conspiracy rabbit
holes and I guess at this point it's
good to bring on the we disavow these
idiots
disclaimer the last one we talked about
was that glass is our conspiracy well I
don't think we got to that oh we didn't
is that in here that's in here I think
next talk about that too dude the it's
all it's like a conservative thing too
she intends to be is the glasses one
neither of no isn't this guy Jack Hinkle
though like a I mean he says he's okay
glasses have changed my life there's way
too much to explain here but uh th this
is kind of a tanky leftwing
thing what does that mean what's tanky
mean tankies are like uh you know how
there's like like uh the neo-nazis who
like idolize like the uh Aesthetics of
uh the weark like the German Army and
they like iron crosses and all that
tankies are like that for but for like
the USSR like like Soviet oh yeah
there's no way this guy's a tanky he has
like the American flag he's like
hardcore Patriot till I die he calls
himself a Maga communist I don't I don't
think it's really worth trying to
understand Tucker what's happening here
yeah um he he's he's hates China
or no he's saying yeah he's saying
China's killing it actually that is
interesting that's what I'm saying and I
he also I think stands Kim Jong-un here
what is this guy who are you I trying
trying to rap trying wait what he's
standing he's straight up standing for
Kim Jong-un this is what I'm
saying what the
yo look at him I could pin this up
on my wall man take a take a bite of
That Snack
how are people hungry in North Korea
when your leaders let snack like
this yeah this is one of the weirdest
dudes of all time uh yeah I I was like
this guy was in the periphery of my
awareness for a while I knew the name
but when you sent this thing it kind of
sent me down the rabbit hole a little
bit more and um yeah it's confusing and
he's just straight up sing for Putin
here it is Ukraine is ending its failed
uh counter offensive with yeah yeah yeah
Putin's the alpha dog I guess Putin
shocks Russian lad with a pat on the
back he dreams of this this
is blessed by glorious
leader what video hold I don't
know looks like he grabbed his ass I'm
being honest oh you know what I
mean grabbed his ass or
dick what it looks
like
the out this guy is so
weird Putin is an Empire Builder NATO
enlargement was not a provoc provocation
George Bush out here the moral Arbiter
of uh of a geopolitics and mass murderer
genocidal freak 911
911 damn okay so anyway this guy's on
some real interesting he's on his
own wave this guy and he's starting that
man is a rectangle in a circle
absolutely yeah yeah
absolutely I am a iron
cross
amang amang anyway he has this thread
going and as far as we can tell he's
100% serious uh he says are jeans real
and if so can you show me a picture of
one he's talking about the Genome of
course the human genome Oh I thought gen
in general about Levi Strauss or like
yeah I need to clarify with the G like
oh okay not blue jean no oh damn there's
a reader note add it it says author
implies that genes don't exist because
he hasn't seen a picture of one
molecules of all sizes can be seen on
Modern microscopes in fact even Adams
can be seen
now okay whatever big Adam he says I
marked the community note unhelpful
because it proves that chromosomes can
be photographed but not genes
reply to this comment with a photo of a
single hereditary unit of a gene if you
can please and then another Community
note DNA has been directly imaged over a
decade
ago uh I wonder if he responded to that
ask the question why despite how many
articles that Community notes leaks can
they not prove Mendel's Gene
theory was menal wasn't menal like a he
was the guy who uh kind of is experiment
no no no no no that's mangalo that's
mang okay Mand mang the uh he was a uh
uhing the Nazis I believe a Catholic
monk um who experimented with plants and
kind of realized that traits were okay I
know about him yeah yeah I know about
him uh I learned about him in college in
my class entitled the secret sex life of
plants which was actually quite a good
uh course propaganda according to to
this course quite an interesting course
is Sean but then this one throws me off
too he goes ask the question uh only
meloid NPCs believe in jeans and then he
posted the
soy compilation featuring me yeah so
that was what really caught my attention
because the the term
meloid it's one of the funniest most
online things I've ever heard in my life
it's so good I just want to pick his
braid a little bit like I want to so
what so what are we missing then let's
say DNA doesn't exist what's happening
why why do we believe DNA okay so again
after going down the rabbit hole so he
mentions the lysenko guy which was the
the clue I needed to figure this all out
so in the early Soviet Union there was
this scientist a biologist
that subscribed to this older at that
time already outdated belief that um
traits don't come from genes they uh
they can be passed on um
um things that happen dur your during
your life can be passed on to your
children that's true there is there is
uh evidence for um okay so you agree
with thisy for well both can be true no
there is truth that um trauma and and
things that happen in your life uh can
be passed on through your genetics okay
there is I guess I'm just a mendal then
no I mean there but I also believe in
DNA don't get me
wrong I'm not saying I don't believe in
DNA but I I've heard that that
environmental experiences and can
memories can be love just sent this this
love said this is me right now you're
such a this this is one of the
memes that we found when we were looking
into this there's a whole
subreddit and this is this yo yeah you
see the double
helix uh I love the community notes the
Neil uh lammer rickan theories of Soviet
biologist
trofim lenko has been conclusively
proven as
false I love Community notes so I don't
know what his teachings are but I have
heard about environmental
DNA is that a thing a here uh thank you
a growing B of research suggests that
trauma like childhood abuse Family
Violence or food insecurity among many
other things can be passed from one
generation to the next here's how trauma
can leave a chemical mark on a person's
genes which can be passed down to Future
Generations very interesting yeah I
think I it totally makes sense to me as
like a um evolutionary mechanism you
know what I
mean so there you go you got no beef
with this guy you actually agree well
that's not true at
all let's just be clear about that about
the community notes that statement and
that's not even the craziest one that
we've seen here's
one um this lady
says
glasses is a conspiracy
which is really
interesting
um check this
out this is the holistic master and we
should we should bring the disclaimer up
for our girl here as
well um this one really kind of took me
by surprise that your optometrist
doesn't want you to know yourist hates
me yo she did the fact that you do not
need glasses that's right you may have
have been told that you need glasses but
that's actually a lie there are mental
emotional physical and even spiritual
reasons why you may not be seeing and
I'm here to tell you that that can be
healed if you want to learn more read
the
comments what's the one thing your
optometrist doesn't want she even hit us
with the what optometrist hate me for
this one simple fact these glass have
changed my life yeah what about Logan
Paul D that's so funny because like well
you you called him out you said that
that video was fake true kind of in a
way see you agree with this lady too
no corrective lenses have been around
for like 300 years or something even
longer maybe even like a thousand years
way older than that so I'm kind of at a
uh lost for when was the first
Collective lens discovered cuz that
is like Benjamin Franklin Frankie boy no
no he did that's what I learned in
nation no he he probably did the bif
focal or something like that yeah shout
out which is not a great invention
that's a weird one cuz how you going to
do like you look down you look up I
don't know it's kind of crazy well they
also found the treasure map on the back
of the uh declaration independence okay
was that was that do D you talking about
National Treasure you talking about
lenses uh the invention of spectacles
attributed to 13 Century but now taking
them off you're making a spectacle of
yourself he but going back to the first
century ad
um they wrote about a glass globe filled
with water to magnify
text you hear that lady a globe filled
with water so what is she doing here um
well let's see we we tuned in we wanted
to break free of the Box she posted a
video with her husband who looks like he
wants to end it
all no glass he's like babe I can't
see yeah he doesn't look too happy he's
smiling let's see do you see it I'm just
trying to get Lando to be in a video
with me and it's proving harder than I
want it to be hi
honey Jesus that man does not want to be
recorded like at all well we tried just
wait till she has kids and I'm just
trying to get L to oh you post that but
that's not the interesting part the
interesting part is uh
somebody on Twitter paid for her classes
she want they wanted to know out what
was going on and fair enough right here
it is it's just a m multi-level
marketing scheme I paid $1 for this
Vision healing Master Class it's just
alone so you don't have to this is my
Saturday morning
cartoons is there no clips one thing
that you're up oh come on I want Clips
lady this isn't my first rodeo no scroll
down scroll down this is a whole bread
mhm okay all kinds of stuff so it's here
I am not a Pharma doctor or medical
adviser oh
okay this is for holistic educational
and empowerment purposes she's like I am
unqualified for this
conversation such an awesome disclaimer
this is just for
fun why do we not
see
medical this looks really well
researched and I love I am a surgeon
this is really cool too the image
here if I had to infer I think this is
all the right here cuz these
are like these are the supposed medical
conditions right let's see refractive
airs myopia
hyperopia she's just she's listing all
the vision you know yeah cataract
glaucoma yada y yada all of them she
said all of them godamn diabet even
diabetes re retin retinopathy lazy eye
we're going to pop the lazy eye back
into place with the holistic
spiritual praise eye
infection what how okay Ethan eye
infections are
conspiracy yeah neurological condition
affecting the visual
Pathways all right I got to learn
more here we we
go um oh same one going down going down
okay this now now oh look at these hazel
man oh you got to read the caption on
this one look at the beauti it says plot
to us now we change our eye now we can
change our eye color I look forward to
becoming a those beautiful Hazel wait a
second chocolate mocha oh now you're
interested is interested well what did
she do put bleach in her eyes or
something well I
mean maybe well this isn't about detox
specifically you can absolutely change
your eye
color doing doing Vision heal healing
Works often affects the eye as well
three eyes of n she straight she
definitely did put bleach or something
in her
eyes I mean weren't the Nazis trying to
do this change eye color yeah make the
superior Aryan
race uh I don't
know here's a
testimonial uh
God this is insane I wore glasses
since I was four or five and Sam helped
me transition out of them there were a
lot of spiritual emotional insights in
addition to the physical aspects of my
eyesight Improvement Sam is a genius I
highly recommend learning from this is
even Nexium isn't this crazy for this is
even too much for
them awesome so there it is and
there's her husband who's regretting to
stay so deeply
it's
awesome actually speaking of making a
spectacle of yourself there was a clip
that I thought was interesting maybe to
watch and let tell me if you think this
is a bad idea or not I feel like we have
to watch it cuz I H you
know did we not watch that oh we
did oh never
mind never
mind H I don't remember analyzing it cuz
there was a lot of dialogue about um the
meaning of the oh
okay oh Jimmy's coming on
Wednesday he is he is well uh James
weiner is coming right yeah no no Dr
James Wier is coming yes Alpha dude says
your friends are trying to sabotage you
that's so true so true it's so true a
lot of people make this guy we know him
he we've seen him in previous videos
with like uh Rolo Tony Browntown dude he
looks so unhealthy man you literally
hate yourself in your life I can tell by
looking at you you cry yourself to bed
at night a lot of people make the
mistake of thinking they need to hang
out do fantasy football and like
that if I'm a true friend of you I want
to talk about your business I want to
talk about us making money I want to see
you be a hero for your wife your family
your kids bro you know there there's
other things to talk about I know to
take their money I know you love
business and making money and all that
but like it's okay to watch a
basketball game can make money in
fantasy football too you know it's okay
man to take a minute off kids absolutely
dominated if not I'm not really a good
friend am I come with me and have this
Guiltless PR let's get shitfaced we can
bet on a football game we shouldn't be
watching that I have no interest in
that at all what if it was a childhood
best friend that you grew up with in
your teenage years love you to death bro
we're Ain hanging out dude he's not for
real like no that's not for real who
wants to lose someone this gu like a
they've become these absolute
caricatures they're just so
funny here's one how to release past
trauma I know he's got good advice son
you can do it now you can take control
of your life you're a man now I don't
care what age you are you'll be 14 in
hearing this if you're man enough to
hear this message you're man enough to
take I didn't check this one
for that you're the king of your life
you build the man you're going to become
exercise make money
all right what do you guys think
I mean money or no friends I don't
know he's our boy knowledge what's his
name I'm I've been uh lot of people make
mistake thinking they J Waller J baller
Waller I think J
baller Justin Waller guys the real world
peak of him man how to handle a
girlfriend women can't replace 500 views
like who even is this guy dude he's
hustling dude you just don't understand
is that the husters University logo the
the chest piece isn't that the same
thing yeah yeah the real world
global he's not like nearly crazy enough
to be interesting that's why he doesn't
get views it's like you got to be like
Andrew tayton be like I I could punch
the son you know is it's just
like oh your friend your friends are
sabotaging you it's like okay cool cares
I think that's uh maybe a fan account
though his Instagram has half a million
no he's popular Jimmy Lee has a million
so right he he did Jimmy hit a
million uh I looked just the other day
and he was at like 950,000 I think it'll
be a million by Wednesday we should we
should throw him a congratulations on a
million should do like a million a
million can we put that together Jimmy
Sam in here yeah yeah let's put together
a million 96 party we should get him a c
he at 956
956 let's get him do a million by Friday
everybody you know the amazing
remarkable thing is a week ago he was at
715,000 we we don't follow him on
account here we'll help you out Jimmy
there's one real follower well if we
want to get him to Millie by uh by
Wednesday someone tell his his team
someone let them know yeah let them know
they'll they'll do it they'll get it
done but even if he's not quite there I
feel like we can still recognize the
achievement yeah oh yeah that it's going
to happen either way you know what I
mean he's paying for it let's put let's
get him a cake let's get him uh can we
put on the
cake something like um so lady with the
lady with the one
eye course hey one eye for one
million women women can replace top tier
men we know that you're going to have a
much harder time replacing me than I
will have to replace you and I don't
mean that from a place of disrespect
women have these expectations of men
they want to be tall handsome rich in
shape good luck this man's on a jet ski
in a suit in a full suit bro I know
that's not fun that's kind of hype as
I got be he's like yo I don't have
time to jet ski bro kind of sick dude
what is he James Bond the only
time I can jet ski is when I'm on my way
to a business meeting that that's kind
of sick dude BR unless you're double
seven you should never be in a bro you
ever try to swim in a full
suit you better be a strong swimmer your
ass is going to drown yeah you're going
down that's awesome bom of theing
the real deal in shape good luck that's
a. guy whereas I can go on Instagram
right now and there's a new class of
18year olds 22 year olds or whatever
higher level men have all the advantages
right there I don't mean to be
disrespect I mean like he it's not
surprising but he just openly saying
like looks is literally the only
attribute that matters in women and
youth
[Applause]
18 would it be you
[Music]
oh him outside of the high
[Applause]
[Music]
school what a world man where he's in
jail
[Music]
I don't want to do that he's doing the
old that's not good I don't want that
one on the
record I took that one up back real
quick yeah that was a good butt but
right yeah yeah y killing me with this
dude I'm so glad we have the button
because like before the button I would
say something up and I would know
it was up so I had to on one hand
like pretend it wasn't up and
carry on because I didn't want to bring
more attention to it right and I'm so
glad I don't have to do that now because
it's and then the worst feeling is when
we end the show and we're like yeah well
that was a great show except for that
time when it is nice that we haven't had
one we haven't had to feel that way in a
while I guess is because of the button
is yeah I was I felt I had this feeling
of like um peacefulness uh and I and I
realized in regards to the show it
really the button is really changed the
game whenever that would happen after
the show you would walk past us and
you'd go like we'll see if I get the
call yeah I know it was a horrible
feeling it really was and usually it was
a good show except for you know one
statement yeah oh
damn you got all you got to be is
18 mhm who is he I forgot about this he
used to walk around like this for years
all his mus video just his fat diamonds
hanging out remember that era yeah he
used to all his music videos he's like
in a suit and he's wearing a mask on his
face wait so he was our Kelly or was it
like a Chris gains type situation no he
was our Kelly wow there's so many of
these what the no I'm telling you
every time he went out it was he was
wearing this wait what yeah yeah dude we
know who you
are maybe he had a pimple or
something maybe he was trying to change
his eye
color um maybe he was doing some weird
in his basement yeah yeah yeah um
maybe God it'd be crazy if we could make
a compilation of all the button moments
when I
retire I saw someone saying that when
that be wild that'd be crazy oh go back
and find compilation going behind the
scenes of all button moments oh God and
release it like too hot for
TV yeah actually I that wouldn't be too
hard because I've already been doing
that as an
insurance right course right or if you
want to Blackmail me you can just do
that now right we'll talk all right
let's talk let's do the 23 and me we
don't have a sponsor today hell no even
with the button man we're still getting
crushed out here yeah so if you want to
consider supporting us I guess go to
Teddy fresh
or become a member today oh yeah M tune
in tomorrow for the member exclusive
episode that Ethan does each and every
week I want to do a member drive and I
don't have any good ideas but I I don't
know if you I've been thinking for a
really good idea I could have been able
to think of one I mean generally it's
like if this many people become members
then this happens that's kind of the
idea right to do like Ethan drunk way to
do a drive and Ethan drunk stream people
love when I get drunk yeah yeah it is
usually pretty fun oh these new um
hoodie colors are out I don't think we
ever really talked about it the new uh
ice dye colors oh yeah I was wearing it
all last week and I kept seeing
everybody say uh they thought it was
cool yeah this color look great I love
the bucket hat too nice nice dud when I
die put my money in the grave uh
hat yep yo I'm happy to see this shirt
was doing really well um and it it
really is such a beautiful shirt like
let me give you a zoom in on the fabric
it's so um feels so designed so
luxurious it really is just a beautiful
fabric and feel and look
phenomenal one of the best shirts we've
made so you guys like that idea I guess
like every so what would the number be
though to avoid me dying of alcohol
poisoning wait you would be drinking and
you wait is the idea that you would keep
drinking until we reach some threshold
no at every signup Milestone thousand
members equals one shot oh okay I see
what you're saying but a thousand seems
a little pretentious doesn't it yeah
100% it's like a thousand it's probably
like well how much you figure out what
200 what's the maximum you'd be willing
to drink and then work backwards there
maybe maybe instead of a whole shot
because that wouldn't last very long it'
be like a
uh you ever done the Power Hour where
you take a shot of beer every minute in
college you never done that no but yeah
you get surprisingly I get the idea
seems pretty straightforward just drink
a lot for an hour Dr beer one beer each
hour right no every minute you take a
shot of beer oh really and it doesn't
sound like a lot but it gets crazy and
having every minute yeah I mean if
you're just just hitting that non-stop
for 60 minutes straight then I mean we
could do it
now no
no no
no like be everybody said no everybody
agrees that's a terrible
idea uh bong rip no I'm not doing that
no amount of money no
amount go for it 911 bong rip let's go
but something like that I don't know if
you if you guys have any ideas I'm I'm
uh I'm interested in it yeah
all right let's let's hop over to 23 and
me we got some exciting results here
guys some interesting ones 500 members
equal compilation of 20 buttons hell no
23 if we do that we'll lose a thousand
members for every button out any any
behind the scenes button reveal would be
the end it would be at the end of the H3
podcast I'm pretty sure I'm not sure
they're all that
bad no most of them are not bad all it's
bearing degrees of bad some are that bad
some are a breathalyzer would be fun too
someone said actually that would be
really fun if I had a breathalyzer until
you crack a certain amount well just to
know okay just to know well yeah let's
uh we we'll talk about it let's uh let's
buy one of those
a impromptu drinking camine stream guys
are wild ketamine stream okay that's the
guy I had sex with who smoke cracken
with
me acid stream I don't know about these
ideas y'all these are bad let's just
let's take like four tabs of asset each
and just see what happens all right do a
poll say should we do a members uh drive
right now or
later why are we doing this right now
what's wrong with right now would you
want because we haven't planned for it
or done like it just seems weird to just
impromptu do this it's a live show dude
feel it'd be better if we plann for it
though yeah we can make it like AIG
definely that's true it would be a lot
better if we plann for it we' need a
Tracker and everything for the members
yeah that's true we should plan for it
may we another another Ben members
benefit that we didn't touch on is that
we're having a live show soon so Early
Access tickets to Live show tickets yeah
and we should say that both times that
we've done live shows recently and had
it early for members the members were
the only ones that got tickets so if you
uh if you want to come to this next one
uh later this year it's not a bad idea
to sign up um hopefully this week I mean
we're waiting and seeing we haven't
heard back but okay let's do 23 and me
guys we got some stunning results in
here that will shock you to your bitter
core we have AB Lena and Zach but let's
review some of the ones we did
previously now mine was uh not
surprising it explains a lot frankly and
if it was up to me I'd have a lot more
oh God it's even worse than I remember
99.8% 99.8% European
P 99 break that down further
99.2% I feel like the I feel like it's
just a margin for air Western Ukrainian
Jew mhm oh I guess that's what asazi
is 99.2 man I wish I had more diversity
trust me if I could go back and throw
some jeans in there I would well you
have a decent amount of diversity if you
look down at the bottom we always fail
to mention that you are. 1% South
Chinese oh my God that's nice it's Trace
what does that mean we I just a touch of
Chinese somewhere deep deep deep back in
your family tree 15 Generations back
somebody one Chinese person snuck their
way in it's not their way
in what do we do about
it wow well that's fantastic does that
mean I can make Chinese jokes or no I
don't think that crosses the threat
point1 brother nah 0.1 nah you need the
1% that's a round down okay right that's
true it is a round down uh but here I am
you know kind of up to be honest
it's a little sick it is a little sick
it's like dude in all the history of my
lineage nobody around with like
someone from outside their friend
group more like their immediate their
cousin group freak and it is it's a very
striking contrast if you want to pull up
ela's Ela has a wonderful uh I forgotten
how ver her uh her results were which is
good news for our boys yeah I got some
genetic Variety in there Northern
Western Asia which would be yeah like
uh Iran Caucasian and Mesopotamian let's
go girl shout out Mesopotamia shout out
number one we don't hear from them
enough these
days that's IR
R yeah but shout out to
the but we like Mesopotamia is the ter
Northern Western Asia she's Arab
Egyptian
and levantine levantine mhm you don't
want to mess with me what is lentine
it's it's like Lebanon Israel Palestine
that whole area yeah she I mean ela's
kind of a she's kind of a
PO why she's North
African she's Arab shut up
Egyptian Liv
that's that's a
PC that's PC
AF uh Western Asia North I mean and then
she has 20% European apparently 7.6%
Italian which was a big deal that was a
big deal I remember time it was very
wait I thought she was 15 cuz I've been
telling people our boys are 7 and a
half% Itali afraid not they're only
three in the half that's right yeah
I know it is you fro and a tiny bit of
ashkanazi 6.3% which is good mhm the
less the better of
that but she's pretty diverse man yeah
that's what I'm saying like especially
in contrast to yours I feel like the
people of Israel are they come from so
many different places and they've really
uh intermingled a lot there's there's a
lot of diversity of background there
although they all look the same
somehow uh but there she go you really
don't I mean you're saying she's not PC
she's passing white is passing white and
PC Dan can you I mean you're think Ela
passes is
white and be like that's a white lady
okay white can we do a poll I want to
know if she has any po
credentials okay Dan is the one who
decides see Ela as a person no no no no
no no no no that's a bad PLL a she P not
do you see well what's the definition I
don't know because du is almost asking
is she white passing you can be a person
of color but white passing well I mean
no it's not it's different like ab's
he's technically a PO well you're half
white I know what you're saying though
you can be a p like okay dude why you
can be a PC and still be white passing
that's crazy doesn't
excl so
racist how dare you that's exactly what
I just said well no but your question is
ask is she a is she white passing that's
not the same thing I want to know if she
a p wasn't what the that's not you said
does she look like a PC dude you want to
load that question harder with more
racism bro my God this is so annoying uh
I just put up your version of the
question is Ela PC now that's a good
PLL I mean based on her background you
know he on down the ha going on his head
like a mashed potato byebye
but we're clocking no is winning but
barely but barely oh yes is taking the
lead Ela is po according to chat by 51%
this is a groundbreaking Revelation
here I mean
Dan do the math Northern as Northern
West Asia Northern Africa bro North
Africa yeah so what is PC I don't even
know cuz Northern person of color well
that's like Morocco and Egypt bro those
are PC's um they're like dark skinned
it's a it's a different mocha you know
what's happening Dan don't take that
label Dan shutting down okay yes is
taking it I'm I'm definitely done with
this
conversation 52% say yes so there it is
but she is white passing I'm just having
a good time come on y let me over
here uh there it is thank you so so much
we love it don't
we that's a
revelation genetically yes people are
saying okay if that's going to come up
Someday I'm G I'm going to use that to
my
advantage and some future
argument um Dan didn't take one but his
dad did sucker right where are you from
Dan you're 90% ashkanazi Jew or your dad
dad is oh I didn't realize you were
dad's so your mom is not ashkanazi Jew
at all not at all that's
good I mean it is if she was 90% you'd
also have Tourette Syndrome or
something you know Balan
saric okay so what's your M where's your
mom from well like I said she hasn't
taken one of these so we don't know for
certain uh part of her family is
Scottish um on her dad's side
they're McKay but then her mom is like I
don't think they like I don't think they
really knew I heard like lvan thrown out
there at one point maybe so maybe like
some Eastern European I think just like
European mut basically all over the
place
nice very
white very white dude is Dan PC Dan is
Def I mean no we can definitively say no
you didn't see the Nigerian in there
should we maybe put a poll so what
percent of okay let me pull this back up
you I thought you were over this
conversation 1.6% Nigerian I'm just
kidding all right I won't I won't push I
won't push Sam did one Sam's pretty
white I'd be
surprised 100% uh got in look at you
white ass the results are in I'm
white it's like every variety of white
though
yeah you're diverse Lee Wyatt British uh
British Irish 33 clocking in here had a
lot more British and Irish than I than I
thought I did that's your majority uh
sorry
Heritage yeah you know French and German
why do they get the
same huh why do the French and the
Germans why are they
together uh because there's a lot of
intermingling I mean those countries
border each
other they don't like each other at
least well they've had some they've had
some issues in the past Scandinavian 3%
broadly Northwestern European 12%
Southern European 30% including 30 22%
Italian yo why didn't you tell me that
sooner
girl you come to meet the
22.6%
Italian that's crazy you should be the
Godmother with credentials like
that Greek and Balan Spanish and
Portuguese well congratulations you're
probably going to win the whitest person
in the
office let's go a coveted award oh you
have a tiny bit of ashkanazi jeuck in
there ashkanazi she's in the tribe I'm
Jewish Jewish tiny tiny bit tiny
bit one of them snuck in there and 2.5%
Iranian at the bottom you see
that now these are the new ones and you
guys looked at them which
is l
I mean it be fun okay anyway so let's do
Zach first now Zach your guess was that
you were full ashkanazi right uh yeah I
believe that was my 100% you were saying
yes so let's take a look and see if you
are right Zachary is oh that's one
color 100 what you edited this nope my
hand to God this is this is what
they gave you yeah dude what the
King Jew in the office bow
down he's 2% more than you Ethan Y what
you are you have been dethrown you got
jwed my friend I am stunned by this
they're like you didn't have to pay for
this it's just one
color they just did a paint bucket and
clicked
yep dude that's nuts I didn't even know
that was possible yeah neither did I man
I've never seen a 23 and me like this
there's just one there one thing you and
Richard Rich King Richard II third are
descendants how's that possible if
you're
100% everyone in Europe is that's just
one of those things you and
King Richard III are descendants of a
European woman who lived around 13,000
years ago you know that's
because look at this Zach just proves
all this well we also found out
it's more which you'll see
later on I won't say right now but I
mean basically according to this you
you're just straight from like uh I'm
just a Jew but the thing is like I don't
I don't think I look that Jewish like
there's not even a
little that's my name but if you saw me
would you say oh that guy's a Jew yes I
say that guy's a rockar to BST
your Bobble there bud well what what
what's the
giveaway I don't my schnaz is it is what
it is I don't think he looks over like
if I just met Zach I don't know if I
immediately what about me yeah
youu I I've got an Armenian
well you're 100% Jill and I'm very proud
of it shabbat shalom I King Richard III
apparently you're just descended from
Adam and Eve I'm King David Adam and Eve
reproduced and had a child that's pretty
much what they say there's a common
ancestor 13,000 years ago and that led
to King Richard and you 13,000 goes back
further than that Zachary your genetics
make you likely to be able to detect
certain bitter tastes mhm interesting
58% are likely to T taste what taste
what B ones just any bitter what the
is this just certain bitter tastes
yeah I don't know why that's this is so
useless and also it's like 50/50 so it's
like yeah there's some other like do you
taste bitter things I yeah definitely
how do you like your coffee Zach wow
this is f uh black there you go there
you go I'm so glad we paid like $300 per
person for this I'm King Jew baby what I
this valuable data King Jew pure bread
all right let's take a look here Zachary
your genetic predicts 69% chance you
have little or no back hair that's
interesting what do you what is it um I
have a little back here can we see the
back and we can we yeah sure let's take
a look let's take a
look and only 8% oh no I mean it's not a
hairy back but you do have back hair I
would say 31% chance that you have at
least some back hair is seems to me that
you're not destined to have a hairy back
no I'm not like super hairy on my chest
you can view full report what what's
what else is there to say I don't I
don't think there's much Zachary your
genetics predict 92% you're going to
have a you do not have a bald spot yeah
I do not y thank you thank you thank
you cheek dimples well it's 5050 so who
cares right not predictive or at all
that's literally the opposite of
predictive you have a clef chin Do you
have a cleff 84% says not you do not you
do not
dandruff well that one's about 5050 too
that's very don't even include those
apparently according to your genetics
you have an 88% chance of having a
earlobe detached earlobes which I do
which is the detached one they're both
detached oh you're asking what do you
mean by that what's the difference you
see the difference in the little drawing
there how it kind of comes down which is
the detached one this one that's the
detached oh okay ring free like like
droopy saggy beautiful I got big ear
loses too so hell yeah D I'm into that
oh yeah D early hair loss 81% chance you
will not experience hair loss let's go
baby before age 40 that's sick dude
bless up 93% chance you have wet sticky
ear wax I do but that that's like all
Europeans have that style ear wax excuse
you 100% ashkanazi je not just European
100% oskan yeah okay I'm sorry yeah um
Zachary your genetics predict you have a
75% chance you have a dark brown eyes
which I do not Hazel Hazel not light
brown they're just Brown dude okay like
a turd wait what does mine say then
because I have beautiful Amber eyes uh
do we have access to my original yeah uh
I do actually cuz I want to I want to
Crunch the numbers more on that here let
me uh let me pull it up finger length
ratio Zachary your genetic predict 78%
chance your ring finger is longer than
your index
finger not quite okay you're in the
minority you have
freckles I no you have few or any
freckles I have freckles they're
primarily on my nose but I don't have a
ton of them then you're the minority
again yeah hair photo
bleaching 55% chance you're experiencing
hair photo bleaching I don't know what
that is I don't know either the these
are actually pretty crap I have to say
is this the traits page yes okay so
here's the traits report for this is so
not worth the money oh wow oh wow Ethan
hair photo bleaching is when your hair
lightens in the sun dimples B wait what
yo it's only
67% they're giving you a one and three
chance of getting a bald spot well I'm
already not so get that out of here I
have I don't have a hairry back thank
you okay
dandruff I do have dandruff I have had
dandr I have to I use Head and
Shoulders all day dude I use that
too man do you do you not have a Cliff
Chin I have a slight cleff oh so wrong
on that one I definitely got fat
beautiful Supple detached earlobes hell
yeah okay here's the eye color thing 31%
chance that's it they did give you a
decent chance for y light Hazel
Amber but that's funny cuz all three of
the kids have brown eyes
well I heard if you try hard enough you
can actually change your eye color I'm
trying I'm think trying to do this
through my train like essential oil
politic training I got you you want some
I have I have I definitely have W wet
waxy hair wait hold on you missed
someone one Dan go up 64% chance you
will not experience hair loss that's
very
low I mean that's very high or low
they're only calling it before the age
of 40 which you're well passed at this
point so this is irrelevant I'm not even
40 yet chance your ring finger is longer
than your index finger that's not
true that's not oh wait ring finger is
longer than in this is ring uhhuh this
is index so not true damn freckles myth
busted
dude hair texture uh slightly
wavy I don't know slightly wavy hair I
would no I would curly yeah 90 9% that's
that's nonsense my mom and my sister
both have super curly hair well H it's
not wavy you'd take big straight up curl
I feel like you just have like very wavy
big curls BR he definitely has curls big
curls I think yeah if you let it grow
out if you look at pictures me in high
school yeah I guess that's true I got
big curls bro they call me big perm man
big
perm newborn 90 59% chance you had
little or no hair at Birth who
cares I don't know 99% chance you don't
have red hair oh you only have 1% chance
of red damn wait are these are we sure
these are Ethan's results yeah okay why
cuz mine was the same for the 1% oh yeah
I'm logged in okay LED in Ethan stretch
marks Widow Peak unow that's another
like hairline related one I do have a
slight widows peig so again it's wrong
this thing sucks
sucks it's just like random is this
just random it'sand no it's not
it's all a game of percentages it's not
random L pretty spot on all right let's
let me see taste and smell let me see
weird and wonderful asparagus I
definitely can spell asparagus bitter
taste can't taste the you
saying but isn't that bizarre because
you have almost the same as sa and all
of a sudden you can't taste it but sack
can taste it he's just a couple perc
difference well that's just our like the
ethnic group yeah it's more there's
more yeah ice cream flavor preference
what that's dumb man sweet for salty
wait so well hold on do you prefer
chocolate over vanilla ice cream no
frankly are you lying just to just to
slam them no you seem like a I've never
ordered chocolate ice cream even as a
child never you're always vanilla I'm
not Li why would I lie bro so you're
always vanilla why don't you just say
that what are you saying I said no he
didn't say that he always orders vanilla
is this revenge for the PLC conversation
no no click weird and wonderful why
won't you answer if you eat vanilla ice
cream I do but I prefer mint and Chip
does this tell you if he's a rectangular
and what chip mint and what chip Ethan
mint and what chip mint and it's not a
chocolate
chip got him dude go to weird
and wonderful bro you're so mad right
now Dan is
100% match a musical pitch oh
50/50 wow yeah you you find the right
pitch about half the time that makes
sense less likely to have a fear of
public
speaking okay I mean that obviously is
true hair thickness this is dumb
man my my my Sophia is a good one for
our
fans less likely to hate chewing sounds
that totally makes sense it doesn't
bother you at all likely to wake up at 8
am I
wish motion sickness
5050 you did all of those VR things and
you didn't get motion signal I don't but
it's 50/50 doesn't mean doesn't
mean and then there was like those
super scary Health ones which we did
look at you're right this thing is total
this is the proof right here
click that How likely am I to wake up at
8 809 what are you why are you even
predicting at that shot you're going to
bed at that time yeah
exactly this is
dumb dumb genetic zodiac where is there
any other uh things or is this
it there's ones about like will you get
Alzheimer's by the age of 45 oh that's
like the medical one here that one's
scary as I already looked at it but
if you guys don't want to look at it I
understand we didn't opt into those you
didn't opt in smart they're really scary
I think it was like a 100 bucks more or
something yeah it was like 100 bucks was
but you can wonder if lupus is on
here ah there isn't
you have a 50/50 chance of having lupus
let's see age related mus uh macular
degeneration increased risk what does
that mean I don't
know wait so I do have VAR what not
likely at risk for whatever the
that is hereditary hemocromatosis
not likely at risk thank you yeah I
don't know not detected not detected
choose whether to receive this report yo
why yo I want that
for wait what's the one what is macular
degeneration oh boy cuz I have aight
fear unlocked click that bro I want
it I feel like they're adding stuff age
related macular degeneration is the most
common cause of irreversible vision loss
among older adults okay whatever oh you
just get some essential oils yeah it's
fine just put some just put some
lavender oil in your ey some you're all
good dude I got Apple I have two copies
of genetic variants we tested okay I can
live with that that's fine
wait go back what's that up and
that one's so up they like you
have to click
too you have to
click to get the result where did it go
it's on the LA the back page you have to
go back one and then go down it's like
at the bottom choose whether to receive
this choose whether to receive this let
see oh
God uh MP multiple adris colon polyps yo
their lifetime increase risk of colar
rectal cancer oh that's actually good to
know I want to know that yeah why would
you not want to know that I definitely
that's one that's actually useful to
know mhm continue like some of the
is
like would you like yes well no no no
like the Alzheimer ones that's not
helpful at all that's just terrifying
same with Parkinson's aren't these all
terrifying huh so you don't want to you
want know on some of these you don't
want to know I already saw those ones
you can leave it yes okay but I was
saying at least with increased colon
cancer you know to like get checked more
right okay let's see well let's find out
oh God take this off the screen just in
like I don't know personal shit's going
to show up here
tutorial what what I think they want to
teach you to not panic okay yeah just
just Breeze through this yeah view the
report let's Jesus it's giving
me anxiety come on
man
all that to say I don't no you don't
have it yes
yes wait but if you go back there was
one that I didn't see it says I'm likely
to get type 2
diabetes what yeah it did this
position stinks stop it good thing I'm
losing weight go all the way to the
bottom typical likelihood that just
means normal oh oh just I have a typical
likelihood I have a less one let's go
right now yeah not bad not bad not bad
so there you go we go right now you're
doing
good like you said lupus isn't on there
yet but they'll catch up they'll add
it nice dude I'm saying though if you
guys do do this don't do the health ones
it's so scary yeah like the Parkinson's
one you know why do you need to know
that it's just terrifying you just wake
up every morning
waiting
haunting your every waking moment
right okay all right so that's me that's
you back to AB or wait no
Zach these ones uh are not that
interesting let's go to the other
ones stretch marks chances are you have
very fair skin
Zach you have a little bit of a unibrow
according to this I do you do not have a
Widow's Peak I do I they got that wrong
about me
too what are you looking at here Dan
nothing I was just seeing if there was
anything else interesting okay so let's
pull up Zach's data
here let's look under the hood hey
Zach 100% you know there's going to be
issues when you're
100% I am
rectangular I do not have
holes
I do not have hes are you pulling up
Zach oh I'm not logged into Zach's
account I'm only logged into yours oh
who's logged into Zach cuz I wanted to
see I am but I think I think he put
everything that he wanted to share in
there that's everything that basically
comes with what we got okay so there's
Zach I guess there is surpris as
now let's go to AB now your prediction
AB was cuz you're half like Hungarian or
some half Lebanese half uh we're
about to I I was told my mom has Irish
descent so Irish half white half Irish
Lebanese let's pull it up let's take a
look take a look under the
hood H looks like a spot
on no surprises here eh it me up
a little bit because I always thought I
was more Arab than white but now I'm
just HT slightly oh that's close
enough man that's basically
5050 not quite 50/50 I'm looking at the
world what's wrong being white dude I'm
just saying I feel like sounds like a
little Reverse Racism to
me I don't know what I am anymore 40%
British Irish what was the other 10% of
the white oh God get that out of here
don't do that to him British Irish Lizzy
in a box me Ian were brothers all along
French and German okay right lizz's your
girl yeah so just that whole Western
Europe but no surprises a 0.1% Nigerian
shout out brother right there W African
brothers let's go it was me toe length
you have a longer big toe I mean that is
so dumb I'm sorry that is just so dumb
they gave you the same King Richard
so that's why we were saying so
everybody gets this King Richard
yeah I think everybody in Europe
probably if you go far enough back how
many kids that man have well it's not
even that he it's kids of his look it's
saying that it shows it in that little
chart it's my my box is covering it
right now but it's saying there was a
common ancestor between both you and
King Richard 13,000 King
Richard right so like the common
ancestor is way before King Richard dumb
bitter
taste Abdullah you can taste bitter
50% worthless it's not even just bitter
it's certain bitter tape it's like
so UNH helpful with less okay so here 90
2% is saying you are not going to have a
bald spot you have good hair jeans bro
God that's that's actually impressive
that's better than me or Zach had I
think hell yeah congrats on that thank
you you do have dandruff I don't
actually ohuh yeah incorrect yeah the
dude early hair loss you will not
dude you got mad hair jeans bro wow new
hairline
King new king Jew new hairline King
I I'm sorry this this is just so
dumb hey AB there's a 60% chance you had
little or no herit birth isn't that
crazy that you just learned
that although you got the highest chance
to have very fair skin so you actually
are perhaps the whitest person we've
tested in this room how interesting is
that it's
interesting yeah but I'm not yeah he's
not Arab he's he's he's English we need
to just start referring to him as
British dare you I'm curious to
see Ian the I'm wondering if AB is more
British than Ian that would be Inc you
want me to instacart some uh beans on
toes did you never do this I I did not
do it no I do you do you know like you
know about cheddar
man do this what's cheddar man it's like
a skeleton they found in England like I
don't know like 10,000 years old and
then they found the relative like a mile
away from from where they found the
skeleton like a living relative yeah
that would be mine but that's awesome
what's wrong with that I'm just saying I
don't need to test it go it goes you
know it's a ladder up there's no tree
there King Richard III for sure yeah AB
the whitest person here congratulations
buddy my uh my brother-in-law was trying
to make me feel better he said that 10%
that's France was when uh Lebanon was it
that France colonized Lebanon or yeah
so you could think of it that way yeah I
mean whatever makes you feel better but
still you 39% to be the highest category
of white do you got to uh drop a out or
is your name like Smith now or like like
brown know it's white yeah it's white
okay and moving on to Lena now Lena you
were saying 100% Lebanese right I don't
think it was 100 but it was close to it
what your guess though you your original
guess yeah yeah holy because both
my parents are Lebanese so so yeah
you're you're
basically Lebanese yep that's what you
are let take a
look yeah oh wow well there's still some
variant here
64% Lee right and then you got a little
bit of Egyptian you got a little West
little of this any ashkanazi jeun there
no anti-semitic she she has Su
successfully evaded the infiltration
um bidder who cares okay here's one for
you Marie
Antoinette comment even further back
18,000 years ago you had a common
ancestor Marette it's like but I'm
surprised AB didn't have Marie Anette
being so
white that should have been yours check
check
dmle you do not have a clein I mean what
the your wax is wet all of us had
that um yeah statistic for the
airax
uh uh Brown oh you have super curly hair
right I do my natural hair is Curly okay
so they're up the curly one cuz
they say 42% slightly wavy eight and
then 39%
straight big curls tight curls that's
what you have right somewhat if less
than 1% dude that's whoa way
off
um okay this is interesting Light Beige
skin Light
Beige oh it's a nice
color
um it's all like 50% I mean it's so
dumb thanks for nothing thanks a lot me
21 in me all right I just don't know if
there's a more Jewish person in well
it's impossible oh my God
cam just uh dug up something really
interesting no man is 100% rectangular
dude oh my God oh my God it's just like
he said
[Music]
rectangular he feels it in his
hole we love him uh no I don't think
anyone could be more Jewish than you
it's literally impossible statistically
impossible it's an honor you know true
honor you know how karate masters they
can go into any dojo and channels
channel the master yeah that's you with
your genetic test go into any
sinagogue throw down the RAB you become
the rabbi I'm the rabbi now that's
awesome well done Zach thank you congrat
I mean that was the most surprising
thank you to my great great grandparents
and uh I accept the award the hsba award
on their behalf you have a lot of
genetic in your families
like ailments yeah um there's like a
whole bunch of ailments associated with
ashkanazi
Jews I mean actually Google it Dan or
some or AB heart disease I guess is one
of them that doesn't count too much um I
don't I I don't want you to take offense
to this I don't have issues that you
have like gird or gastone problems so
you're like the Unicorn ashkanazi yes
yeah yeah yeah you're like really truly
The Chosen ashkanazi yeah yes almost you
could say a
perfect a per a a uber man you could say
maybe I just feel like Hitler couldn't
even be mad an Uber mench Uber men we
need to breed
you with other Uber
mench yeah Zachary Uber
Alis Uber
Alis this a yeah here's a list of
ailments you should have Zach okay it's
a long list Jesus it's so long yeah
tach disease
tax TX is a rare and fatal genetic
disorder Jesus that affects the central
nervous system my
God no thanks
gers uhuh this an inherited metabolic
disorder that can lead to the
accumulation of fatty substances in
various
organs I can't say that I know anyone
with either of those those sound real
rare uh cystic
fibrosis um certain mutations are
associated with ashkanazi what is s I
don't know what that one it means I've
heard of that before I think I've seen a
commercial
yeah lungs digestive tract and other
organs I don't like that sounds not fun
so Friday are we doing a Sater your
place I'll bring the Hala sure okay
canavan disease this is a rare
neurological disorder that primarily
affects ashkanazi juice this is this is
like our own disease like we have
that other people don't even participate
in
name and pick disease certain form of
name and pick disease are more prevalent
in ashkanazi
Jew
um I guess those are the real wild ones
I don't see anything like gird and stuff
yeah but uh Shalom brother it's good to
be home this is
basically this is my hair I brushed it
out but like when I don't it's super
curly this is me just trying to make it
look puffy but my hair's crazy I'm you
bring it back I want to see it so you
forgive the expression you have a a jeo
absolutely okay in the truest in the
truest
Essence
yeah all right well
[Music]
shalom
what well because I said the place that
Sam was going to get lunch I realized as
soon as I I shouldn't have said that
that was a horrible idea is this place
good it's fire it's based on that one
show right no what okay should I button
again I don't I have no idea what you're
talking about so I don't know if that's
ident
not but that also was that's not going
to give it away way too obscure man I
don't even know what
oh
oh so
it's it's this right I don't I don't
want to give it away
oh oh I don't think I ever tried it we
ordered it once to the office I remember
did it hit now's your now's your
chance I think you liked it it's a vegan
joint you know the the potatoes probably
usually slap at vegan joints they have
they have the best Tots in the world cuz
they don't that's all they have is
potatoes they're vegan I'm shaking bro
that's all we got I don't know what to
think about hater tots yeah they
probably hit pretty hard does this upset
you
love yeah you should try it I mean
it's got to be better than eating red
meat I'm getting nervous bro I'm not
going to lie you don't even want to
ingest it it's not it's not bad love I
had your hesitation it it is actually
very good well I'm I'm I'm going to pass
but thank you trying to be a good boy
wow I'm I'm on my weight loss Journey
you can get a protein style no I just
I'm waiting to have my meal cuz I want
to eat with Ela the kids a there you
go cute give it up give it up I'll bring
it to seder on Friday bring my meal to
seder than shabbat
shalom all right let's talk about eight
passengers what everybody wants to hear
this woman is demonic I mean I you know
what to
say hey I'm surprised she didn't like
kill one of them frankly I guess she was
close to on the way she was pretty close
yeah um some of the stuff is really
disturbing so
again I'm going give a disclaimer up
here up front that uh definitely trigger
uh warning for people sensitive to these
kinds of topics of
abuse
um
here's the 911 call this is really
disturbing you
guys I mean it's it's interesting in in
the context of everything but it really
paints just how dire the situation was
exactly um so here it
is and again skip this if you're
sensitive to this kinds of stuff wait
six minutes I don't remember being six
minutes I think I heard in a bridged
version
happened I just had a 12-year-old boy
show up here at my front door asking for
help and he's uh said he just came from
a neighbor's house and we know there's
been problems at this neighbor's house
he's emaciated he's got tape around his
legs he's hungry and he's thirsty okay
first of
all great that guy did a great job
of yeah calmly telling them exactly
what's happening yeah that was good is
he is your door
locked did you let him
in hell
no no I'm sitting outside with him on
the on the front patio this poor kid had
the presence of mind to know that
like he was being so abused he asked him
to call the police that's
pretty I feel like a small child
wouldn't think to no you know yeah
pretty
bad he asked us to call the
police what he's very afraid are the
neighbors out of their home or is
anybody looking for them that you can
see uh no we are homes are far enough
away I'm not sure how did you get out of
the house dude that's evidence they live
in the middle of nowhere 100% that's the
neighbor far
away thank you I'm going to take a
victory dub during this horrifying call
yeah sorry guys I'll never miss
opportunity to say I was right no matter
how in opport no matter how bad the
timing
[Music]
is out he said you just left through the
porch at the neighbor's house
um her name is jod
hilderbrand
so that's her partner she let her
business partner of the mommy
podcast in prison and starve her kids
man see old
Partners not
funny
love sorry about that sorry you came all
the way from Sweden just to make jokes
like that come on man on cold for sorry
about that she lives to 911 Street on
911 man you come to our country on 911
yeah and make those kind of jokes shout
out while listening to a 911 call whoa
the layers are nuts right
now um
anyway yeah out in Cay the houses are
far apart so he walked just under the
block to get to our house he rang my
doorbell and asked me to call the police
wait he said he walked just under a
block to get to my house well that's not
very block can be very far if no a block
can be far I mean if you're talking
about not even a block though it's a
half of a block well if you're talking
about your next door neighbor that's a
pretty that's like significantly far
away yeah like they cannot hear any
going on I don't oh come on oh my God a
block can be however long the block is
you the man just told the police they're
too far away to see why are you
defending them Dan I'm not defending
them sounds like it but half a block
just doesn't you're defending Utah
wherever they live yeah I
see does he seem to be under the
influence of drugs or alcohol I don't
think so but he's very thirsty and uh
please get him some water
man I don't think he needs Mar any
unless I'll let the cops decide that but
his ankles are taped up and he won't
tell us
why put he has duct taped around each
ankle yeah there sores around them I
think the a good chance he's been
uh oh and he has been around his ankles
I mean his wrists as well okay this boy
has
[Music]
been this kid has obviously
been I think he's
been damn he's so shook up he's been
detained he's been
he's obviously covered in
wounds you didn't want to say it was so
horrible yeah I mean imagine dude the
the state of this kid the neighbors
crying just at the the sight of how
poorly treated
ah my heart goes to that child he's
obviously so brave and resourceful to to
get out and communicate that and go to I
mean yeah just want to love that kid and
give him a good home that he
deserves so sad and then we we'll find
out later she actually even from jail is
trying to uh right trying to uh
hurt him it's so messed up so evil just
the idea of a child wanting to get away
from a parent it's supposed to be the
opposite like if something happens
they're supposed to run to the parents
like I don't know the idea of a child
escaping their parents is so
disgusting yeah these are the hardest
stories for me to yeah to listen to
because it's just so perverse yeah I
mean
what it's just like poisonous all of it
and then she has a bunch of kids too
like for why do they do
that you know and she has a mommy
podcast yeah bro and a family Vlog
Channel on YouTube like let's not forget
the context of this and you'd think
having to like shaning up your kids is
harder than actually just being a good
mom kind of you know what I mean it's
like just be a good mom it's not I'm not
saying it's E I don't think so you don't
think so you just duct tape them she
just she didn't even feed them or give
them water they just duct tape them in
the basement yeah check on them
like once a week I suppose yeah that's
up it's definitely
not I mean going to jail is definitely
going to be uh right probably
wish although I don't think she has the
presence of mind to think through that
at all yeah let's get the paramedics
headed over that way okay oh that's a
good idea
too let's see um has he told you where
his mom or dad
are haven't asked him
that you know your mom I really got oh
yeah I'm sure that's that doesn't matter
son do you know your mom and dad
are well
actually I don't know where my mom mom
is but I do know where my dad is he's
not here no no worries okay he doesn't
seem them he says he knows where his mom
is
but he doesn't know where his dad
is that's
correct is his mom home he he just says
he doesn't live around
here area
is your mom around here have you seen
her lately no
I he doesn't know where she is right
now does he know his
mom's
name what's your mom's
name Ruby
Frankie he's it sucks dude because I'm
sure he doesn't want to even
give them the name his cap Ruby Frankie
is his mom's name
okay how do you spell the last name f r
a n k e f r a
NK okay and does she live in the
area no I'm not sure where she lives
he's U he's trying to help us but he's
okay we don't want to stress him out too
much the officers will go over all these
questions with him anyway I just want to
stay on the phone with you until we get
some help there okay can you ask him any
other children were in the home he came
from
okay
um was there any other kids up at Jody's
house 10 and 14 and they're they're
still at this house oh no there was two
other so there was three in total I
thought it was just two so there's three
and they're still in the
house oh
God can you be that
ask um are they tied up as
well
um what's the deal
with are they um are are they being held
he can't even say it it's interesting
it's like too horrible to say are they
are they do they have wounds on them as
well nothing bad going on with us okay
it's just okay so they're they're able
to walk around the house and
everything well okay he says
everything's fine with some grain salt
yeah okay he says he
uh what's happened to him is his fault
he's find me by got him sitting here my
wife he got him water and something to
giving him something to eat cuz he's
really he's hungry and uh Victor young
he's he's hearing his stalking
feet so he he
[Music]
escaped I'm glad that he was able to
make it to he could be safe how do Ruby
and and her partner how do these people
find each other you know what I mean
like in all this big wide
world two absolute heartless Psychopaths
have come together to make a mommy
podcast and lock children in their
basements that those are two very
specific
interests Facebook Facebook that's not a
bad guess it's a Facebook group yeah I
don't know but how do you even like how
do you even approach the question you
know hey can I ask you a question are
you into torturing
children that was a test you passed most
people be like no and then she's like
that was a test you passed we can be
friends authorities soon found another
child in a similar condition at a nearby
home and took that child to the hospital
and four other children were taken into
the care Department of Child and Family
Services they should just be pulling up
now let me know when they're with you
okay we'll do is Jody up there right
now okay Cody H is up there right
now okay there's someone I wouldn't mind
getting a knee in the back from
the
police is that
okay can I say that yeah yeah I guess
well you know generally they
reserve the knee and the back for uh
other kinds of looking
people can I say that yeah Dan yeah
you're
so she may come looking for him here
soon but
uh he's not going to
obviously right we need the cops here as
soon as possible I'm just asking where
he is now yeah she's a uh she's a bad
lady we didn't realize how bad does he
have anything with him
but uh no he's wearing a long sleeve
shirt and shorts and uh it's a way too
big for
him um can you tell me um what color the
short okay the uh the ambulance is
here
okay
so that's a good guy the
neighbor um handle that
well man I want to see the interrog
ation videos you know what I mean like I
want to see these these ladies get
they're just so vile man 30 years
she got right not like literally yeah
just to be
clear um what are you talking about 30
years she got 30 years didn't she or she
not sentenced yet charged for 30 years
no even 90 right yeah I think you're
thinking of the uh St show
dude it's interesting that the neighbors
go we knew this jod lady was bad but we
didn't know how
bad all right so that's the
call um and it certainly does help paint
the the picture Ruby Frank made her
first court appearance over the weekend
virtually from a jail in Utah where she
remains on no bail thank God I mean how
do you get bailed for a crime like that
you
don't until her hearing uh
although Andrew take out Bale
though he's in Romania to be
fair here's a screenshot of
Ruby appearing in
court look at you
miserable God I hope you're just
hate you're just suffering you
pig you should be ashamed of
yourself so she's doing her court
appearance like this I wonder why
they wonder why they do it over
Zoom did they start doing that now since
Co just cuz it's more convenient maybe
yeah I mean it certainly is you don't
have to transport her ass there and back
yeah makes sense police guards they
realize it's actually an efficient way
to
do she doesn't deserve to get out of
jail smell the fresh
air um here's v a video of Ruby and
Court oh it was shut down for technical
difficulties was this meant to be live
streamed I think it was either the
public got a hold of the zoom link and
then they had to shut it down it was up
it got up to like a thousand people on
the zoom at once and then it was yeah
I'd be I would be very surprised if this
was meant to be viewed publicly right
somebody got in the zoom that's so wild
I think a lot of the zoom links are
public they publicize them but obviously
it doesn't really work when there's
someone famous was in there yeah the
story is so big enough for example
there's like that YouTube stream of a
court court room always going of of like
a judge and stuff judging people live
let's see so it's probably public so you
represent Miss Frankie I do on the video
with
us miss Frankie can you hear me yes have
you received a copy the information in
this case
yes are your guards denying you food and
water good Y no I mean yes good they're
they're under strict orders to make you
suffer and to starve and uh deprive you
of
water inform the court that Miss Frankie
and I have all Rie her btim the
information she understands it she
pertinent questions we wave the reading
of that at this
time uh
I and we're ready to for with it I would
make one motion I understand that the
code defendant is assigned to judge
Walton I guess nothing's really
happening here yeah it's just a random
procedural
yeah Ruby okay so here's where it gets
really you guys so Ruby in her
defense she starts saying oh no I I had
to
um imprison my kids
because they were essaying their
siblings and other kids in the
neighborhood her kids who are singled
digit years
old have the
their it's speechless it's it's spe I I
just like even if that's true that's
clearly your fault how is that not like
so
obvious something's happening in your
home that's causing them to think that
that's normal behavior
obviously H just it's unbelievable here
I mean here's a Tik Tok that explains
the uh situation pretty well
here her court hearing just ended and it
will only lasted 30 minutes but let me
tell you what she said so they said at
times she broke down and she even made
shocking claims that one of her minor
children Esa their siblings and SAA
several other family members and
children in the neighborhood over the
years she's I can't believe she's
blaming her kid yo your honor my son
really sucks he's like a giant piece of
crap so I had no choice but to lock him
in the basement okay you're good that
sounds good you you can
go that defense alone just proves how
psycho she is I mean it's shockingly
insane and callous she actually like
hates her kids it sounds like the
youngest ones
especially yes her ex-husband was there
with his attorney and at the other table
were the state attorneys and what
appeared to be Frankie's two older
daughters also accompanied by their
attorneys as well so when this entire
coure hearing was supposed to be about
her she turned it to blaming her
children pinning the blame for her
behavior on her children she went into
horrific detail about how one of her six
kids abused other children she also
claimed that one of Frankie's kids began
looking at p word I can't say at just
three years old okay again as the father
of a four-year-old and a one and a
half-year-old there is no way for a
3-year-old to look at pord unless you
literally open it on a t and set them in
front of them are they typing they can't
read or write how are they accessing it
you lunatic insane there's she's
clearly abused these kids in more ways
than if this is all true it's 1,00%
something that's going on in the home
how can you say
that
three-year-old that's that's nuts and
actually really
sad three-year-olds don't even they have
no concept
of sex or even like gender or attraction
at all it's all everything's just
like
H such a
demon and in one of the most shocking
claims she said that her child you're
the mom you know that you're
incriminated yourself right like this
kid's three they're not going to arrest
the
three-year-old been essaying a younger
sibling for years adding that eventually
two of them begin to abuse other
children she also claimed that her
children played a padding game with each
other and did not go into further detail
this is crazy that she decides to let me
just make these allegations these crazy
allegations blaming my children for how
I'm acting she said that in May her
child confessed to essaying 20 people
including cousins and neighbors she
provided no proof of these sickening
allegations Go figures the courtroom
went eily silent as she made these
disturbing claims because I'm pretty
sure everybody was in shock that she
decided to turn this on her children and
then the judge said that her alleged
abused children will then need to be
placed in a home with no other children
she's delusional she's psychotic and if
your children are acting out like that
like you say they are then dude I hate
her so much for that and so here's how
she's still with her her kids as
a result so because of what she
said her she claims that her child
assaulted a younger sibling for years
eventually resulting in two of them
abusing other kids together like what
like what what they're what they have
like this coordinated uh it's nuts it's
sick it's so bizarre doesn't
make any sense it's well if any of this
true again it's her it's under her
supervision I feel like she's just mad
at her kids she just trying to harm them
them for she definitely hates them
yeah she hates them so she's just you
guys are not if I'm going to be in here
you guys are well frankly I hope that's
true because if any of this stuff
actually happened to them I mean this
just horrific this further trauma
Ruby said her child confessed to
assaulting 20 people no shot that
doesn't even make what does that mean
the result is that because she said this
stuff about her kids her youngest kids
then the judge ordered that he can't be
in um held in rooms with other kids in
so including his family I think so one
of these kids I think it was the
youngest one is now being held in a
separate foster care from his from his
siblings because of what she said until
they can
uh rule on
it um how sick is
that yeah so she's still terrorizing
them even even from
prison despite calls from the Utah State
Court for Mike's to be muted and cameras
to be turned off sound effects and music
blared through the portions of the
meeting Jesus soon attendees began using
profanities and explicit name calling
dropping multiple F bombs before someone
pointed out the virtual hearing is still
considered an official courtroom people
are playing sound bites and during
the court hearing oh well that's
that's actually shame because I
would have liked to have seen
that do you uh how do you plead uh Miss
Frankie oh what's
that I thought the was
whyde the uh we're still catching up to
the technology
folks I read that they were threatening
to hold people in contempt of court for
playing sound bites and yeah
right
so um this is a quote you guys realized
this is a real courtroom so you can be
held in contempt said an attendee whose
screen name simply read
Bob there's got to be a way to mute okay
yeah they're working on it they're
working on it there was over 1,300
people I'm reading and people were like
playing baby noises and like dogs
barking and they're not ready
they're not ready for all that it's so
weird cuz it's been a thing for years
now they're doing over Zoom like
publicly right this is such a
high-profile case but they're using Zoom
they need like their own proprietary
software like they're using Zoom but
also with zoom you can mute all
participants except the I don't know
Force mute but like who's actually
operating that just some Rando cler CL
doesn't understand how it works so
yeah they need some kind of training you
know what I
mean uh here's some more surfaced videos
too that came up um this is all stuff
that happened before my God people were
watching in this it's unreal man
it's unreal she's popular I want to get
out of this
conversation oh and her family's still
vlogging
right this was her right who her
families are all
vloggers I think so family vloggers uh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah the judge then said that her
alleged abusive child will need to be
placed in a home with no other children
so he separated from
his family and other kids that's crazy
she has that power over him still it's
actually really
sad that's
man that's
sad that's crazy that makes me wonder if
she knew that when she said that because
who's going to believe that it's I like
I what love was saying that maybe she
just wants to punish her kids
continuously yeah she definitely hates
her youngest kids especially it seems
like
but how can you even utter those things
into existence because even if it was
for Revenge I mean it makes her look
like she did that
stuff I don't know who
knows I want to get out of this
conversation oh oh no this is an
uncomfortable conversation we must
have M are you angry at me listen I gave
Julie a tongue lashing that that will
not ever be repeated nor
recorded I don't I don't want to see the
little girl's face I prefer if it was
blurred
out there's no reason for us to see just
use your
imagination you know what I
mean she told her daughter to sleep on
the bathroom floor the Eve came and
got in bed with
me at about 2: this morning she's like
Mom I peed the bed which is not like her
she pees the bed maybe like once every 8
months like it's been a very long time
since she wet the bed I was like oh darn
it that's all right just go sleep on the
floor in the bathroom
what you actually like you record like
what crazy
people and that wasn't even her being
mad she's like oh sweetie that's okay
just go sleep on the floor in the
bathroom the
I'm cleaning the sink I'm cleaning
the
countertops whopping the floor I'm
stalling I think I'm ready now I think
I'm ready to leave I put on a little bit
of lip gloss and that will be as much
stalling as I'll go and so she woke up
this morning and she's like Mom my
vision is really blurry like more blurry
than it usually is Kevin just came in
he's like I think we need to take
emergency room I said well let me take a
shower and then I'll be out it's been
it's been an hour
so she's almost like proud of how that
she's like abusing her kids she says it
proudly cuz I guess her whole philosophy
was like I'm tough and kids need to know
their
place te she she treats them like
livestock maybe worse than livestock
uh Jody's niece okay so this is her
crazy ass partner's niece
MH and um validate these types of
behaviors through dreams and Visions she
would have these dreams God came to her
and told her oh that I had had an
abortion and so no matter what I said I
was a
liar and then that and also she was
convinced that every word that came out
of my mouth was a lie and that you know
gave her rationale to put duct tape on
my mouth and that's why I was always
duct taped oh because oh she was going
to kill those
kids if they didn't if he that brave boy
didn't Escape yeah that's crazy I said
was a lie and that needed to be like
physically reiterated in to to show that
I like to as a reminder that everything
I say is a lie
so and also people saw people saw me
duct taped people saw that these things
were going on and other than like the
few people that like went to Bishop and
being like hey something's wrong at
church no one did anything is because I
wasn't getting better I was getting
worse is that there was still sh there
was still sin in me that wasn't coming
out that I hadn't confessed yet and she
was so hyperfixated on me confessing sin
and she again she was she was convinced
I was a sex addict I was a drug addict
he I'm trying to make you so physically
uncomfortable that it forces the sin out
and so that's when she started I would
had to sleep outside in the snow that's
when I was um an office in in um
Thanksgiving Point there was a little
side office closet it sounds like her
partner
was serial killer yeah I mean the
meeting of great minds
that's it sounds like want GMO
interrogation
tactics down at the church we like to
interrogate our kids like as quintan
moay yeah she sounds pretty Disturbed
this lady so they probably met through
charge then maybe you were wondering how
they met each other I saw people in the
chat saying that uh this uh jod person
uh was one of the kids therapists oh
yeah is how they uh is she credentialed
like a real
therapist like a therapist have to guess
probably not let's see she saw she saw
um Jody's uh niece duct taped mouth at
church and she said hey uh she was at
one point but she had her license put on
probation by the Utah clinical mental
health counselor licensing board for 18
months back in
2012 um there is a website that is just
Hern name.com jod hilden maray an.com
that uh I don't know who created this
but this seems to be a website for
documenting all of her sins essentially
is this from before all this came out
that would be interesting see have all
this info on her this fantastic here's
info license on probation wait what did
that say about p word porn there oh she
specialized in porn
therapy porn addiction
therapists discussing a patient without
permission with uh with what do you know
it Mormon church
leaders religion is the greatest um
cover for sadistic freaks they all flock
the religion because they you can just
you can get away with so much under the
guise of being
religious h no but she she saw her
tactics at church and she was
inspired you know
I want to be like
her room it was like a little bit bigger
than a closet but it didn't have any
Windows it had like a table a
chair an actual closet and that's kind
of about that's about it so that's where
I when I when I was pulled out of school
and I started living with her full-time
because she worked I went with her to
work and that's where I stayed and
sometimes she would lock me in it
sometimes she
wouldn't um but I was not allowed to
leave I ran away three times from her
house I went to a neighbors I went to
the police if this is fully true but I
from what I understand she's been
diagnosed with many many um issues
including psychopathy so um you don't
say she like as far as I'm aware she is
a psychopath sun room off the off her
bedroom that's so sad you know the more
you learn it's like the police knew
apparently the I read somewhere the
police were called like 30 times to the
house wow yeah like they knew them
something was up and I
mean I'm confused about the whole Child
Protective Services
because on one hand I hear about kids
being taken
away from like fairly healthy houses
where it was just you know totally
unnecessary and they're breaking up a
family and then you hear about things
where they come to this house 30 times
and these kids are literally calling the
police for help
it's probably the church I mean all
those fleets are are Mormons you know
they're all part of the Mormon church
and they just they all covered for each
other it's also just crazy to think that
they were online for so long undetected
I was looking for some posts in the subr
yesterday and I found a post from five
months ago saying content court on eight
passengers really uhhuh and it had just
like 15 up votes oh yeah there
wasn't much in the in the thread but oh
wow yeah wow
mhm wow here it is some people's radar
for sure wow see there was even people
on YouTube were like I I had never heard
of them until mhm this is just a picture
that says Reddit
nice
weird anyway it says content Court eight
passengers they kind of are getting
content corded right now they're getting
for their content
true wow actually you know what
though hearing all this I do think
that thankfully because of that boy's
bravery he saved all their lives oh yeah
this was going to end way
worse uh if that Brave Little Hero
didn't
Escape what a
guy can you
imagine
hero saved his siblings
lives anyway you guys want to talk about
Jimmy Fallon speaking of
demons so that's basically it you know
uh with the F with the a passenger for
now
and it's sad you know but that like the
weirdest part about this whole story is
that they were the freaking family Vlog
Channel like it doesn't get more ironic
Mormonism is law in Utah someone said
yeah that's what I thought like
especially in Salt Lake City everybody's
Mormon you don't get elected unless
you're Mormon they don't vote for you
right because there's so many did they
live in Salt Lake City or like the
outskirts
of blood
boiling yeah know so that probably did
have something to do with
it oh swoop appar apparently did a Ruby
video a while ago eh yeah like eight
months oh it's really good I definitely
recommend it really wow swoop always you
know swoop always does an incredible why
didn't I never hear about them yeah it's
a shame I never
heard I am re Jody be like I am
rectangular I am rectang this just a
rectangle on I start
[Music]
fit
the hilderbrandt website's been up since
2001 wow what January 2001 so there are
people that have been desperately trying
to sound the alarm
here okay the they're in
yeah they had a mommy podcast like guys
I I I don't even know how to process the
the the irony of this they had a
mommy mom I want a VAP podcast together
on
YouTube
wow phenomenal
man there it is
folks yes
sir what it
is um we got Jimmy Fallon we got the
Danny Ma I know
see it's a lot of depressing stuff
fortunately because the next one here I
wanted to talk about was the Danny
Masterson one and again we all know he's
guilty I don't want to talk about that I
did want to talk about Ashton Kutcher
and Mila 911 their careers as we said
right um which maybe is a little
amusing just how like out of touch and
insane they are well I just uh I was
saying before the show listen I you know
I think Colleen still got this on lock
but for the steamies this year
all the bo had it unlock huh who that
Colleen has it on lock but for the uh
worst apology video category at the
steamies this year me right I think
at least there's a little bit of
competition asht Ashen
and I just said I think Colleen has it
on lock wait you might be right but we
definitely have like another nominee I
right Ashton saw that and was like she
can't just run away with he literally
got at least try they literally stood in
front of you know what's that Meme where
there's like protecting the Sleeping
Beauties from that's them over a twice
convicted awardist uhhuh yeah like you
why did you do this so yada yada
everybody knows what happened he got
convicted 30 years another religious
cover up he's part of the a big part of
the Church of Scientology right which
I'm pretty sure had a large part in
enabling him to get away with this for
so long
um but here's where it get includes
Ashton we'll just start from
there uh as you guys know they're former
co-stars of his on the 70s
Show and they put out they wrote letters
of endorsing his
character his
character what is it matter at this he's
already
guilty it doesn't matter that he was
nice to you
or that he was a confidant he was proven
in court that he's a freaking twice
rward bro you got to put you know what I
mean like yeah friendship over right so
this is a this is a common thing in big
sentencings like this where um the
defense afterwards will try and submit
letters of character to basically ask
for leniency in the sentencing to 20
years versus 30 years essentially right
why would you do that did they not think
this would become public maybe uh I
think that may have been part of it uh I
think
also um this is pure speculation but
it's not listen the SC Church of
Scientology very famous for uh
blackmailing people right and uh oh
Danny Masterson has been friends with
Ashton Kutcher for a long time so Ashton
Kutcher may not have had a choice in the
matter let's just put it that way oh
well that would certainly change the
Optics MH and just to know they sent
them before they were before he was
sentenced the letters but same thing
before he was he was actually sentenced
before he was found guilty found guilty
yeah he was not found guilty yet yeah so
then why would they ask for lenience
though that doesn't make any sense you
sure about that are you sure about that
I me what a letter of lenience would not
make any sense if he wasn't s if he
wasn't found guilty already yeah
entertainment weekly says uh why they
wrote the letter supporting Danny before
our sentencing before sentencing found
guilty already that's what he said I
think we were just a little no I asked I
said were they found guilty you said no
okay it's my mistake it's a big
difference I mean because if they wrote
it before he was found guilty then right
it's a lot
different um but they didn't here's what
they wrote about him he also said an
extraordinary standard around how you
treat other people bro he
do you did you guys know that he
was just are he just
got there was an incident where we were
at a pizza parlor and a belligerent man
entered who was berating his girlfriend
the letter from Ashton ker wrote we had
never met or seen these people before
but Danny was the first person to jump
in and defend her yeah but did you read
about what did you hear about what
happened what happened after that I
don't give a how he treated you or
your wife if he was nice to you you
clearly then have no say in what should
happen to him because you were not
affected by the horrible things that he
did like it just the Cockiness of
like writing a letter of character
because our friend like you are
not involved this is not you have no
right he was nice to me though I saw him
defend this girl one time in a pizza
joint how are you going to undermine the
victims like that and try to try to like
make their Justice less because he was
your friend and he was really nice he
has no pizza experience yeah and also
this man committed heinous crimes that
he's going to jail for you know that
right you want him out I
don't did you see the the like line
about how they said um he's not a danger
anymore and um like his daughter would
be better off if like her father were
out with him and it's like what about
the two daughters that he raped so did
this did this apparently happen a long
time ago or recently the the the ours I
think a while ago both during when they
were on the TV show is when it took
place oh so he's changed so we can move
past this he totally different I'm sure
the girls have moved on yeah no this
story is just so he continues it was an
incident he didn't have to get involved
in but proactively chose to because the
way this man was behaving was not right
right but he right okay he has always
treated people with decency equality and
generosity well not always can think of
two instances right
MH he continued while I'm aware that the
Judgment has been cast as guilty on two
counts of our word by force and the
victims have a great desire for
justice I hope that my statements uh to
his Char Testament to his character is
taken into consideration That's crazy
dude what the
he goes while I acknowledge he's a
horrible person and is great and and the
victims want Justice I'm willing to
stand in the way of that because he was
nice to me this seems so stupid
that I can kind of believe it's and I'm
famous and Powerful in Ashton Kutcher so
I have leniency maybe in Sway in the
court was so bizarre to think that he
can do that well if they have dirt on
him it must be really bad well there's a
Tik Tok Linked In This that has um a
theory of possible blackmail that he has
on him cuz Ashton was like involved in a
homicide case it's like it's crazy
I forgot right he was one of his
girlfriends he was dating uh was
murdered do you know about that and he
was the last person to see her well he
found her body no no that's the theory
oh he he saw the body his fingerprints
were on the doorknob and so he went to
the police after his we'll watch the Tik
Tok when we get we have more he says he
continues I do not believe he's an
ongoing harm to society and having his
daughter raised without AE a present
father would be a t a tertiary Injustice
of itself this dude thank you for
taking the time to read this that's
crazy man that's
nuts it's stunning what is there any is
there any evidence at all B I mean this
is all
just guess right with the
blackmail other than it's all
conspiracy the the non conspiracy brain
theory is that they've been best friends
for 25 years and he's standing up for
his friend I just don't want to give I
don't want to be careful not to give him
too much of the benefit of the doubt
although you don't cuz if he was coerced
that means he probably murdered
someone no I'm riding on their
and I hate them um it's an interesting
tick Tok however well because and then
the weird weird part is Ashton's whole
uh adult passion has been uh helping
kids from being sex trafficked he's been
like a huge
proponent of ending that so if anyone
should understand the consequence of sex
crimes should definitely be him right he
also he has a a charity about helping
like sex trafficking victims too yeah
his whole I mean he's all been all about
it
um this is what uh Mila
said part of Mila's letter said Danny
has consistently displayed a profound
sense of responsibility and care for
those around him what are you
writing he demonstrated Grace and
empathy in every situation except to be
it within the in entertainment industry
or our personal lives his steady support
and understanding presence makes him a
Rel iable source of guidance and comfort
to all of
us I wholeheartedly vouch for Danny
Masterson's exceptional character and
the tremendous positive influence he's
had on me and the people around
him his dedication on leaving a
drug-free not a rape free life those are
like such hurtful words his dedication
to Leading a drug-free life and the
genuine care he extends to others make
him an outstanding role mod own friend
what dude they had to all run over
someone one night or something it has
right because this is too insane right
yeah they definitely killed
someone in my
opinion uh you know in my
opinion but reportedly oh based on
nothing reportedly over 50 people okay
including Ashton and Mila provided a
statement Deborah rup who the
that Deborah Joe R oh they're the
parents in That 70s Show oh right those
are the parents they both letters too
Smith why yeah that one hurts kurtwood
Smith is maybe they're just old like
Boomers I think they probably also suck
they got to be really old now like how
old are these
people uh they're pretty up there but
what you're saying what they're
like like have dementia and they don't
realize no someone could be like hey can
you write this letter but no they know
he's 80 no he's not that old you know I
don't think they none of these people
wrote them I think it's like lawyer
draft them and then hey do you want to
sign this no but they have to approve it
that's gave personal stories
yeah I still I I literally cannot
believe that they were self-righteous
enough to think that they could stand in
the way of someone else's
Justice uh Kurt word Smith is 80 years
old why would you want to defend hag I
can tell you your honor R Kelly was a
tremendous friend of
mine uh he he used to we used to have
the best parties at his house here H her
and uh he was super generous with his
with like you
know drugs and alcohol and we just had a
really good time together can you be
lenient that's
nuts the letters were shared by uh Tony
Ortega on
substack and you know that it won't
matter like what judge would
consider any of that it's insane
not this one apparently it's not the
first time they've defended their friend
who was found guilty of two counts of
rward in May and will now sures three
decades in prison in a conversation with
Esquire Ashton asserted his hope for
Danny's
innocence okay fair but he was found
guilty so it's time to you know jump
he clarified I don't want him to
elude the law but I wish for the truth
to show he's innocent that's a fair
statement
but it's not what happened I can't know
I'm not the judge the jury the da the
victim or the accused I'm in no position
to
comment he killed someone
mhm like come on potentially allegedly
no that's not the fear he allegedly
killed his girl the theory isn't even
that but I but that said I
wholeheartedly agree with you Ashton
coacher definitely murdered they killed
someone together yeah together with
Danny mson
let's just go with that did you see do
you conclude the video of Ashen the name
of the serial killer um that that that
actually killed his girlfriend was the
Hollywood
Ripper sick name um murer I think Ashton
I think Ashton Kutcher is the Hollywood
Ripper oh yeah I think they got wrong
guy he he'd be like I am
[Music]
rectangular that's what serial killer is
saying say that about her boy that's his
favorite
[Music]
song Oh this is so
wild you
know that's Hollywood for you man they
don't give a
dude one minute it's I I'm not in a
position to comment the next is hey come
on give the guy a
break he's a good dude come on man come
on man
um Danny and all of his victims were
members of the Church of Scientology red
alert and three of the women he claimed
he and the three women he claimed the
three women who claimed he awarded them
at his Hollywood Hills residence oh so
he had like a ML and
everything uh
wow sign Scientology
huh
uh here is oh yeah so here's their
apology which is pretty weird as well
and cam is setting it up for us um they
included why does that look dud why does
that photoshop look so legit pretty good
those are holding yukes
for real thank you looks true that is
coen's arms on the right there
too so here's the apology
they're like wow we could have never
anticipated that people would be
mad that we defended a twice convicted
our worst and asked the judge to go easy
CU he was nice to me one time who could
have seen this
coming it's not like uh Hollywood has a
reputation for like being Insidious
scumbags to cover up sex
crimes let's play into that
stereotype we are aware of the pain that
has been caused by the character letters
that we wrote on behalf of Danny
masteron we support victims no we have
done this historically through our work
and will continue to do so in the future
this this is just horrible cuz like you
didn't so what are you so where where's
the apology
exactly actually they didn't they're not
they're just acknowledging they're like
we know you're mad we support victims I
hate them both but Mila Kunis could have
tried to look a little bit more genuine
you're an actor damn it are you kidding
me right now you look so bitter and like
you're being forced to do this and we
support victims we always have
no you just didn't so explained to
me except twice yeah what the you
always have except
twice we have done this historically
through our work and will'll continue to
do so in the future couple months ago
his family reached out to us and they
asked us so it's just a couple months
ago so this is like after everything
that's
happened right this is in full awareness
of the crimes he committed and his
punishment or I guess before sentencing
but his guilty verdict to write
character letters to represent the
person that we knew for 25 years so that
the judge could take that consideration
relative to the sentencing you know he's
like a s
businessman seems like a smart
guy you could have said no bro like
easily just say
no sorry but no not happening which is
why I think he murdered his
ex-girlfriend in my
opinion it's pla it's possible yeah he
was he was yeah I
agree the letters were not written to
question the legitimacy of the judicial
system or the validity of the jury's
ruling we know that they were intended
for the judge to reap um and not to
undermine the testimony of the victims
nobody thought that morons it was to ask
them to go lenient on a twice convicted
awardist which innately goes against the
victims and the judicial system well the
victims I mean it's okay to ask for
leniency the judge doesn't have to give
it right but they're still
undermining the victims and yeah and
Ashton literally just say we it was not
meant to undermine the victims right or
question the legitimacy well he even
acknowledged that he goes I know they
want
justice but I'm going to take it away
because he was really really really nice
but I'm an investor in Uber your honor I
don't know if you knew that about me I'm
an angel investor and like Uber Eats
your
honor he's been on Shark Tank and stuff
these people are so full of themselves
these silicon yeah he's a m he's
like a mhm he's a huge uh investor 30
Mill he turned 30 million into 250
million with
Uber great I don't know if you knew this
about me you guys but I like kind of a
big
deal yeah kind of like a tech I'm pretty
rich you guys
yeah so can we get some like
lenience or or retiz them in any way we
would never want to do that you did and
we're sorry if that has taken place dude
this is the worst a this is like all the
bad apology archetypes I'm sorry herea
I'm sorry you're upset yeah total
100% this what this is is just like
after someone is essed and then their
friends are talking to everybody and
they're like nah he wouldn't do that
he's not that type of guy and it's like
all you're doing is adding more guilt to
this victim who's dealing with so much
guilt already like it's it's just I they
are horrible horrible people it's
actually worse because he's already been
found guilty yeah like it's somewhat
defensible to be like hey the guy I know
wouldn't do that but then when the jury
says actually we're we're we're going to
convict him because the evidence says he
did it right then it's a whole another
level to be like he wouldn't he's a good
guy I still think he's a good guy yeah
it's he did do that but he is a really
good guy you guys should have seen him
in that pizza store that one place
man the way he stepped in with that girl
dude I'm telling you showed some empathy
really good guy really
good the victims or retiz them in any
way we would never want to do
that and we're sorry if that has taken
place so we're sorry if that has taken
place not we're sorry for doing that
that is what took place they've said
that I believe I'm so curious how they
don't have like PR people around them
that helps them with this kind of stuff
because this is so blatant even honestly
if I I was like why even apologize cuz
this is worse than saying nothing it's
worth than yeah cuz before it was just
text that won't go viral that much I
mean obviously I it's good that it did
but why apologize so dumb just
prove how dumb they are there's so much
I feel like
um market research now and making a good
apology yeah like y'all gotta get you
got I need to go into crisis management
or something exactly that's what
apologies so D also Kutcher and Kunis
sounds gross together I'll say it
keris
keris although that being said I
probably have more experience
apologizing than almost anybody on the
internet that was where my mind
went a lot of practice a lot of practice
it sucks that their first one had to be
about this you know they could have
learned you
know wow man you guys suck dude
you guys suck and now I know that
forever about you guys and I'll never
forget how bad you guys suck y forever
911 never forget bro forever though meis
um did she not bathe her children oh
yeah that was the recent thing they said
they don't bathe their kids regularly
something like that unless they see
visible dirt or like she doesn't bathe
or was it just the kids I think it was
all she she said it about the kids and
for those Reasons I'm out
um let's see oh people were saying that
um shout out to toer Grace who never
defended him oh this is the onion wait
hold on toer Grace comes out in support
of giving Danny Master's electri
care oh in a heartfelt letter
addressed to the judge overseeing his
form former that 70 show co-star uh toer
toer Grace came out on Monday in support
of giving him the electric share while
I'm aware Danny is facing a prison
sentence of 30 Years to Life based on
his character he should be executed
immediately in the most painful violent
way possible dude that is awesome man
the onions sometimes they hit they hit
pretty hard
sometimes
holy hilarious that is so
funny oh god dude they're so it's so
funny to link like an onion link on um
on Twitter because it's just a headline
and no like pretty much no one knows
it's
fake uh let's see shout out to youan
yeah we talked about this a few months
ago Ashton Kutcher Mila Kunis only bathe
their kids when they're visibly dirty
that's such a crazy headline do you know
how dirty kids need to be to be visibly
dirty just like covered in Phil
like this is not the onion if I don't
see dirt you ain't dirty boy just like
if I ain't seen DNA then how do you
prove it's real stretch I don't know
said when I had children I didn't wash
them every day kuna said on armchair
expert can't wait to see her back on
that
show I wasn't that parent that bathed my
newborn ever
ever however Kutcher 43 said if you see
the dirt on them clean them otherwise
there's no point no
point and they had to make an apology
for this they go no we wash our kids
they walked it back no point you like
being clean don't you bet you don't show
up to an investment uh meeting with dirt
on your face smelling like
oh God here's the worst I didn't
have hot water growing up so I didn't
shower much anyway kuna said who spent
her first seven years in life uh in
Western Ukraine I love that attitude I
didn't grow up with hot water so these
kids don't need
it it's funny it's awesome Kutcher uh
who was raised in Iowa has no excuse
offer no rationale but explain that I
wash my armpits and my crotch daily and
nothing else the nothing else ever
nothing else ever I got a bar of lever
2000 that delivers every time so you're
telling
me that okay so to watch his to wash his
dick would require him getting in the
shower how else are you going to wash it
he's right there he just drops trout in
front of the mirror lathers up some soap
and just that seems like it Target
strike dude he he must have definitely
killed someone in the shower he's like
no it wasn't me everyone knows I don't
shower right right right I've never
showered in my life
show you will never find me anywhere
near a shower trust
me but the PA allowed that they both
wash their face oh good could your out
for workouts to get all the he doesn't
wash his ass like I was thinking at
first like okay well like he didn't say
it I was thinking at first it's like
okay if you're not going to sh like your
armpits and your crotch yeah that's
probably like the most stank right so
like at least you are taking care of
does count as crotch perhaps
because it's all kind of there I guess
we could give him the benefit of the
doubt but also we're without evidence
implying that he's murderer so right
we're not really feeling that charitable
towards him there's some evidence
actually that's not there is some
evidence he's a
murderer there's yeah right there's more
evidence that he's a murderer than there
is that he isn't we're more sure that he
killed somebody that he washes his
that is true right yeah there is
more evidence of that than his
getting cleansed so we're giving him the
benefit of doubt in a sense
right look at these disgusting
freaks listen if you don't want to Kelo
was the most annoying character on that
show I know I'm just going to say it I
agree I didn't I never cared for Kelo
agree not that funny did you know he's a
angel investor in Uber though I didn't
well now you know put some respect on
his
name here's my homie he's just he just
got finished raping
someone he's a good guy
though I'm going to write a letter in
defense of him in 20 years and ruin my
career that's you
idiot that's what you sound like right
now
um let's see what else we
got is reported that uh yada yada
Danny's ex-girlfriend posted on her
Instagram
stories wo his ex now is this one of the
victims or just an ex
okay it's one of his victims but not one
of the victims which verdict was guilty
so there were three accusers this is one
of his ex's that she did go to court but
it was not Char on this charge okay wow
so he has he has even more accusers than
these two yeah he was only they were
only able to prove too because literally
said listen if we if we offended the
accusers we're sorry not if yeah you did
just say it dear Ashton oh this I
did this is nuts also victims everywhere
literally they are
so they are horrible people this feeds
into the murder theory listen to what
she said darare Ashton I know the
secrets Your quot Role Model keeps from
you for you ones that would and you did
you forget I was there you were on
speaker phone the night you called Danny
on February she remembers the date
February 21st mhm that's that's the day
the girl yes oh no so okay so there is a
reason for this
Theory the theory is not that you'll
watch the Tik Tok and then we'll talk
about it I heard everything I heard the
plan in my opinion you're just as sick
as your quote
Mentor what wait okay if I'm the police
I'm going to I going to go and ask again
to
clarify I'm leaning into the meme that
Ash Kutcher is a murderer that isn't
actually the theory the theory is that
he saw the body and didn't report it I'm
still asking questions cuz that's a
crime yes that is a CRI for sure it's
still bad it's still bad and I like to
just go with the idea that Ashton
Kutcher is a serial killer he might be
you explain it no no no I'll keep
reading dear M I pray you begin to
process what you experienced as a child
on that set oh yeah can you pull the
interview of him saying he made out with
14-year-old her on set I can your old
interviews are very telling I encourage
everyone to watch them and decide for
yourself what you hear and see do so
before they get scrubbed from the
internet I also know what happened in
Toronto and after question if that's
what you view as normal relationships
with a big brother figure then I feel
very sad for you and I hope you consider
getting into therapy you all must forget
I was there the whole time those five
years of that of that 70 show I remember
everything jeez he's
he going to kill her
next right yo the police need to ask
some questions I mean I I I'm not in
favor of like you know re-traumatizing
people but she has information right I
mean makes sense that they go
ask
right I mean if we can put kushan behind
bars to make sure he doesn't kill
again he needs to be stopped he he needs
to be stopped man
by the way here is
um this this interview is nuts dude
people back then the the
social
norms were
insane this man went on a talk show this
is from the subreddit that's
insane with 10,000 points he was on the
uh Rosie O'Donald show I think I read
yeah O'Donald listen to what this guy's
saying listen
is when she was she was 14 when we
started the show I was like 19 right
right and they're like okay you guys are
going to be making out in this scene and
I'm like thinking like this like
slightly that's probably your first kiss
ever right he was my first kiss what
some a bet you made with Danny about our
first kiss no it wasn't the first kiss
like a second or third kiss it was the
first it was like the first week no it
was not the first week whatever let me
tell you what happened no let me tell no
okay I've never kissed a guy so I was I
was so I mean you know Ash was
attractive and I was a 14-year-old
little girl and I was extremely scared
for my life sure and he was very nice
about it he was like oh don't worry so I
was like okay then Danny goes and goes
dude I'll give you $10 if you French
kisser what would you sck my sck your
tongue in my mouth or some what no no no
no no $10 you're making it sound like it
was like really okay D we had a little
side B going like which
waswe not you know like you know you're
kissing on the show or boyfriend and
girlfriend you would use tongue right
Rosie I mean you would it depends what
kind of an actor you are I guess AB why
would you want to tongue kiss a
14-year-old that just is so up I
love how he incriminates Danny too Danny
was trying to get you no no it's Danny's
fault it's Danny's
fault inappropriate relationship with a
fortune Natalie Portman and then and
then the host is even like the like
she seem a little uh she didn't really
lean into it as much as I was expecting
to be honest let's see this like I guess
it depends on what kind of actor you are
nobody said anything bucks that I
wouldn't do it and of course I'm like
yeah sure what's the deal you and then
the cop showed up and you got arrested
pretty much they should have but they
didn't did it and he CLA to this day he
did my God so he's like Yo dude I
bag that
14-year-old and she's like he didn't do
it he's like I did do it I did that
isn't this insane I mean what the
this was on TV they took this show on
the road
man I swear I
swear did it he never did it I didn't
let him I think he tried but I think my
mouth so yeah you did the old teth dude
I felt her up bro I I gave her tongue
and I felt her up for sure I did that
I did that on January 1st 1999 I
felt up a 14-year-old and French ker me
Ashton kusher encouraged by Danny
Masterson just trying to say so awesome
I'm saying this well not under the
influence of any substances of any kind
say this in a clear here's my
ID my driver's license I mean
essentially
right
block yes the tee block like yes I
never
got you didn't you didn't Ashton just
admit it
she's 14 she didn't you stop it Rosie's
like just please don't admit to this
please I did that Bro
right she would know that was not the
first you had turned 15 by then no she
was 12 but I know it there's a big
difference that one year makes the whole
world change no all right then we're
coming up with the guy who has a name
that should have been chased for Show
Business Wilmer Vander I don't even know
how to say it what's the point yeah
Danny will be here as well don't go away
Jesus rosie no followup huh yikes Rosie
that's weird I mean like dude this was
in 2002
so 21 years ago it's a long time yeah do
seem like that long to be like yeah I
assaulted a little girl on in camera and
and I told the story on shows CU it was
awesome and I'm glad I did
it it was awesome I'm glad I did it hey
Rosie
Jesus chist everyone up there is trying
to like prevent him from saying it I was
like a I did that no no no for sure no I
I remember the
man it's so insane man here you'd have
to you have to skip over one but since
we're watching this I think you should
watch this one next okay I have it
highlighted another is in the do or from
punk in the duck okay it's number 16
number 16 thank you ABY mhm uh where's
my cursor where's the F okay there it is
number 16 yeah I got it highlighted oh
so who's this person posting
these uh the same person that posted the
uh the the victim the one that his ex
yes his ex posted this
clip right oh a 2003 clip of Ashton
kusher on Punk has resurrected and it
shows the 25-year-old Ashton Kush you're
saying this about 15-year-old Hillary
Duff
oh
no oh
no oh no no no no so he was on like a
world tour because this is 2003 the next
year yep MH he was like I want to
kids bro this is the year I'm just
saying it yeah I want to go on the
rooftop and Shout It Out to the world so
you know what uh well let's watch this
first and then I have another
interesting observation about Hill is in
Lizzy Maguire she also has an album out
um she's going to be in a movie called
Cheaper by the Dozen and she's one of
the
girls that we're all waiting for to turn
18 bro along with the T any 15year old
yo
yeah why wait till then
bro you
know so what I was going to say though
is the weird thing in lie of all these
clips of him being horny for teenagers
is uh he was married to a woman like 20
years older than him for a long time
about that yeah so he maybe he just
likes that there's a age thing he likes
or there's a lot of age gaps in this
man's life or maybe he looked back at
these clips and like they're so
bad I'm going to need to date older
woman and start start an organization
that helps children because this is
marry a mil going back in time to beat
the P accusations that was a really
weird relationship he was like in his
20s right she is 15 years older than him
uh so it's not the worst worst I've
heard of
worse how how old was he when they got
married uh they got married
in uh
2005 and he's so right now she and she
was 40 yeah he's in his late 20s by then
that's fine he was about 27 in 2005 yeah
it's
fine but it is interesting and so
apparently Mila was 14 she lied how do
you lie about your age and get a job in
a Hollywood Super Famous story about
that 70 show and I I've always thought
how the do you lie about your age
you know in retrospect that's impossible
I feel like it's I feel like
they wanted to cast her and she was too
young and they told her to lie dude and
they or and purposely looked the other
way impossible they have to register in
the system payroll they have to get her
social security number all of her info
thing not lie about your I think after
she was cast they realized that she was
too young supposedly and at that point
they were like well she's too good we
can't recast her now that's how the
story goes That's How The Story Goes but
I really do wonder if they knew all
along and that that was their way to
like handwave the fact impossible they
didn't know her age apparently at the
audition she said to them I'll be 18 on
my birthday that's like what she says in
all of her
interviews which would be technically
true yes on a birthday will turn
18 oh man this is a whole interesting
Iceberg huh God he's probably not liking
this uh there you go Ashton Uber
though Uber he did the Uber thing so
moving on uh there's more there's even
more
um spec so here's the speculation about
the
blackmail
um number 15 is where we are right yeah
MH nothing better than a little Tik Tock
detective wrote a support letter to the
judge in Danny merson's trial I didn't
report on this yesterday because I'm not
going to lie it was hard to swallow I've
always loved these two and I've always
respected Ashton Kutcher for the fact
that he's done a lot for trafficking
victims if you haven't already seen the
letters this one is miles's letter you
can pause to read and this is Ashton
Kutcher's letter but one of the victims
named Chrissy Bixler who dated Danny
Masterson from 1995 to 2002 just posted
to her Instagram stories after finding
out about these letters before I get
into what she posted if you're
unfamiliar with the trial Danny
Masterson received two guilty verdicts
out of three she was the one that the
jury did not find him guilty for she
accused him of graping her while she was
sleeping but because so wild the way the
people skirt around saying like
forbidden words
graping does that really
work together the jury did not find him
guilty she posted this to Instagram
saying dear Ashton I know the secrets
Your Role Model keeps for you do you
forget I was there you were on speaker
phone that night you called Danny on
February 21st 2001 I heard everything I
heard the plan in my opinion did she cuz
this is like very explosive what she's
claiming right now on an Instagram story
like she's accusing him of a pretty
serious crime that she has can attest
to that's pretty that's pretty big
deal I'd be surprised if an authority
doesn't come and ask her questions about
this man you know you're just as sick as
your Mentor you must have put that date
on purpose because if you look up Ashton
Kutcher February of 2001 you might
remember this story the chilling details
of the murder of Ashley ellerin and the
Hollywood Ripper trial in February 2001
Ashton Kutcher arrived to pick ellerin
up for a date but she didn't answer the
door because she had already been
stabbed to death by accused serial
killer Michael Gargiulo the next day
when he learned Elin had been murdered
he reached out to police he said he was
worried because he put his hand on the
door knob while trying to open the front
door my fingerprints are on this door
and I was freaking out I told an officer
let me tell you what happened so hold on
hold on hold on he went to the police
before they found the body or after no
no no after because he needed to let
them know why his fingerprints were on
the doorknob so the theory is that he
went to pick her up for that date and
saw her dead body he testifies that he
saw what he thought were red wine stains
but people are theorizing that he saw
her dead body went inside and then
didn't want to be involved in it so he
called Dany and Danny was like just go
home let someone else find it so like
that's what people are speculating is
that certainly happened cuz like you're
going to pick up your girlfriend yeah
she doesn't answer you have a scheduled
dat you're not
answering the lights are on like you're
going to you're going to find out what
happened you're going to walk around the
house you're going to look in you're
going to try to get in cuz you're afraid
maybe you know hopefully she's
okay if that is
true it's got I feel like it's probably
is true to leave your loved one laying
there that's so crazy and then well he
said he saw red he he testified in court
that he thought that they were red wine
stains so he he looked through the
window that's not even plausible he
looks in the window sees red wine stains
and then goes okay cool I'm going to
take off doesn't make any sense well he
had to explain why his fingerprints
blood does not look like wine I'm sorry
and she's not
answering no I don't buy it I think he
killed her in my opinion of
course I agree thank you and you agree
with my opinion yeah seem seems most
likely in my from what I've gathered MH
I don't know lein had been murdered he
reached out to police he said he was
worried because he put his hand on the
door knob while trying to open the front
door my fingerprints are on this door
and I was freaking out I told an officer
let me tell you what happened as for
Mila Chrissy writes dear Mila I pray you
begin to process what you experienced as
a child on that set your older
interviews are very telling I encourage
everyone to watch them and decide for
yourself what you hear and see do so
before they get scrubbed from the
internet I also know what happened in
Toronto and after question if that's
what you view as a normal relationship
with a big brother figure then I feel
very sad for you and I hope you consider
getting into therapy you almost forget I
was there the whole time those first 5
years of that 70 show is this it is she
just a read it is there more interesting
yeah that's it oh here she reads a
little bit more I remember everything
she then reposted this tweet where it
says Ashton and Danny always treated
toer badly toer has never liked Danny I
learned this while doing my early
reporting on the then allegations now
conviction so yeah apparently tlur who I
guess people were giving him for
never hanging out with the cast yeah is
now Vindicated and he left the show
early too oh I'm waiting for that I want
to hear from
toer Topher knows something
against Danny she added to that by
saying Topher was bullied by Danny
masteron and isolated by most of the
cast because Danny's like a cult leader
Danny hated Topher because Topher didn't
bow to Danny like his other young
castmates I love Topher if I so much as
said hi to Topher I would be given a
scolding and then ignored by Danny it
broke my heart he was the only guy on
that set sounds like a good guy man I'm
going to test to his character integrity
and a moral compass that's my experience
I was there she's not the only one
speaking up because toe for Grace's wife
also posted to her stories Ashley writes
to every grape victim that is R I'm
sorry grape his grape just throws me off
every time it feels very silly sounds
like
wine you've been graped into a nice
vintage which sounds horrible I did not
mean to you graped sorry should I button
that no I think it's super weird that
okay people on Tik Tok do that thank you
traumatized by witnessing Society debate
and focus their attention on what is
going to happen to the greatest I see
you and it turns out there were more
cast members from That 70s Show who also
wrote support letters for Danny
Masterson and that would be the actors
who play kitty and Red
[Music]
Foreman you know there was a bunch of um
grape victims in Portugal yesterday say
what oh god oh jeez mass casualty event
this is what Ashton saw when he looked
in the
window who did this the grapest the
grapest in Portugal are graping
everybody oh
yo that's actually insane yeah I
saw this video million liters yeah of of
wine that's crazy what rivers run red
the Streets Run Red there's somebody cry
oh God this is like a national tragedy
I'd be out there with National
tragedy I'm saying I mean imagine how
much work and effort and resources went
into making it's a lot of grapes sad the
grap pers are back at it Grapist The
Grapist man I'll tell you those
Portuguese Grapist are the
worst nothing I hate more than a
Portugal Portuguese
grapus then ignored by Danny it broke my
heart he was the only guy on that set
with integrity and a moral compass
that's wait I already saw this yeah it's
done did I watch it already yeah you
finished yeah so I mean shout out to
toer and his wife we love
them that's right not being besties with
a rapist Venom we stand them forever we
stand
Venom that was your show toer by the way
they all try to act like it was their
show it wasn't their show it was your
show okay thank you right I mean he was
the main character he was the main
character
yeah
uh I didn't really ever watch that show
I wasn't ever super into it I loved it I
watched it I wouldn't quite go to love
level but I watched I watched it back in
the day was always a skip for me I don't
know why I think I was watching Seinfeld
runs
instead that was my yeah I was
going to say and Fez wasn't about to
write a letter CU he supposedly dated
Demi Lovato when she was 17 and he was
29 oh also Fez has accusers of yeah
I remember he he was getting in some hot
water I'm pretty sure Demi lado
literally has a song that's called
1729 oh god oh
geez what did what do people say
about him she has a song called
yikes um I hear about the murder though
kushan was a witness in the trial he
testified that he was scheduled go on to
date the night of her murder February
21st as
his ex was his ex posted on
Instagram kitcher told the
jury uh
that he last talked to her at 8:24 p.m.
to confirm their plans to attend a
Grammy after party hello you you're
going to find out where she is that's a
big
plan hey we're we're planning this
Grammy after party I'm just going to
ring once and
leave 0% chance zero
zero zero do you hear me or I mean in my
opinion in my
opinion zero in my opinion
0.1% in your opinion let's leave a
little 01 just in Cas I've been through
too much of this at this
point um she was found dead the next
morning by her roommate investigators
believed that she had just gotten out of
the shower when Gargiulo gari
Garo stabbed her to death after entering
her home he was dubbed the Hollywood
Ripper was sentenced to he was sentenced
to
death wow kers quoted saying I remember
the next day I heard what happened I
went to the detective and said my
fingerprints are on the door I was
freaking
out the first thing I thought about when
I realized my girlfriend was brutally
murdered was me was my fingerprints were
on that
door there that is huh little bit of a
heavy uh episode but there it is a
little bit the beginning was fun though
I like the rectangle guy I mean dude
that I am rectang
rectangular feel it in my
rectangular I feel it in
myang also we uh crowned a new king Jew
here in the office today that was big
big moment bro and again listen I never
wanted that Crown bro please take it I
don't want to be I don't want to be I
don't want wear a crown on my wrist baby
right there King Jew baby what what the
Rolex wait what there's a crown dude oh
you be the oh I see the crown on your
roller okay yeah dude oh yeah dude
100% hundo dude hundo my
dude um Ashton never showers too pretty
weird dude wears my fingerprints that's
pretty funny got that crotch
Rod oh wait he doesn't that's the one
thing that he does he does bathe is his
crot um can't let that crot
R sad that Aston has canceled and we'll
never get part two of these amazing
movies we need part two of all these
Steve Jobs thing I forgot about that I
wanted part two now he's cancelled what
what did Steve Jobs die in that movie he
played Steve Jobs in no but in that
movie did he die I think so
spoilers it's job
resurrected he doesn't he hasn't done
the best movies in the world
no uh Butterfly Effect uh reindeer games
dude what happens in Vegas there
essentially half of them are the same
movie Just Married what happens in Vegas
no strings attached they're like all the
same they're like here's the script he's
like I don't need it yeah I've three
times this movie posters all look the
same too yeah also it is crazy if he did
Kill that poor lady and then made cheap
to by the Dozen a year later wait what
was that movie about just family movie
Steve Martin's dead of like 12 kids just
like a happy movie yeah dude Cheaper by
the Dozen that means I'm getting rid of
them bro getting rid of them
attached but that's all of course uh we
don't know that he did that that's in
our opinion right mhm
yep although there doesn't seem to be
much evidence that he did do that seems
like that one serial killer probably
there's a lot of DNA and stuff in the
apartment I did notice in that story but
do I believe he didn't know she was dead
hell
no 100% sure he I'm just kidding I think
after that Instagram story there's
something you know and you know who does
know for sure you know who does know for
sure Danny Danny Masterson and they're
and VAV EXO facto EXO Scientology Church
m hm Tom Cruz knows Tom Cruz probably
knows y That's pretty interesting Tom
Cruz is the key to all
this why does and why's Tom Cruz
involved well because he's like the king
of the Scientologist basically no I know
I was just saying how is he did he jump
out of an airplane shoot into the
roof the chimney yeah that
actually wasn't Ashton that was at at
the door it was Tom Cruz wearing an
Ashton Kutcher latex mask like in
Mission possible
usort technology to fake fingerprint so
that he could frame Ashton Kutcher I
heard he parachuted into the chimney and
cleaned up the crime
scene yeah and then out the Chim he
actually didn't even pop the
parachute shot straight down right right
into the chimney and then slowed himself
by sticking out his arms on the walls of
the chimney I remember that yeah it was
sick
actually all right we got to go it's
super late it was a hell of an episode
but uh sure was we had to talk about it
all one way or the other Jimmy Fallon it
turns out is not the worst person of the
show yeah we'll save him for for
Wednesday so he can be the worst person
in the show yeah yeah he deserves his
moment in the
Limelight Jimmy
[Music]
Fallon All right y'all thanks for
watching Everybody it is Monday so let's
go out there and have a great great week
everybody let's get in the gym get it
let's get in the gym no rise and
grind everybody and grind no
excuses it was a grape stain he saw
grape stains oh it all
[Music]
connects very interesting have a great
true happy 911 I hope you all have a
good remembrance what's a good 911
remembrance
meal meal like a cupcake with two
candles no no come on that's tasteless I
think just something just something real
American McDonald's Hamburg like a Big
Mac something not hello
no something American funny that's funny
I actually I don't even know if I can
make those jokes anymore what did you
yeah you don't have the past bro you're
51% white bro you're you're British
you're a colonizer dude I don't hear
your voice frequency what did you say I
said something that's not Hello H just
make sure you eat something that's not
hello yeah i don't yeah I don't think
Americans eat anything that's hello they
do not intentionally yeah but doesn't
have to be blessed to be hello true same
with koser needs that good old blessing
that blessing baby he's that good old
blessing boy you know what I'm saying is
that blessed
homie all right members thank you guys
so much we'll see you guys tomorrow for
see you next Tuesday be back for
everyone else on Wednesday let's we
figure out that membership Drive yeah
we'll talk about it okay be
fun thanks for talking me out of that
talk to you down from the ledge let's do
it right you know let's do it right my
friends thank you for being here see you
next
[Music]
time
rectangular I am
rectangular